Uh, don't, don't, don't, don't,
don't bum, bum, bum, bum,
bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom,
bom hate fucks going on.
Party people.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast brought to you by Squarespace
score,
hair space.
If you've never been
and you need a website,
so stop what you're doing
and go check it out.
It's the easiest way to make a website.
You don't have to go to somebody anymore.
Even though I've gone to somebody
in the past, my next website,
I'm going to try to make myself
if I had that kind of time,
I sort of have that kind of
time, but not really. I mean,
I guess if you just like put it in a
few minutes every day, you could do it.
Brian's been banging them out
while we do podcasts. He does.
He's done like 20 websites. It's that
easy. It's super easy. It's not just easy.
It's the way it's set up. It's, it's,
it's set up like they're
really good websites.
Like it used to be that you had to learn
how to fucking html shit and you had to
learn how to,
you know,
put all those little weird squiggly
letters that you never use it in an email.
You have to figure out how to use all
those strange keys and arrows and shit.
You don't have to do any of that anymore.
Just go to Squarespace and you don't
even have to pay money to try it out.
You can go to squarespace.com try it
out and then if you choose to buy it,
use the code word Joe
and the number seven,
all one word Joe seven and you'll save
10% off your first purchase on new
accounts, including monthly and
annual plans. It's a sweet deal.
You can set up an online store.
They work on android phones,
I pads, I phones. They're pretty
dope websites and it's easy to do.
Check it out. Mang do. Remember that
guy used to go chill? What was his name?
Check it out of my, check
it out. [inaudible] he was
in Scarface. Angel Salazar.
Angel says, ah, Eh, that was this
whole thing. Check it out. Check.
And he used to be
everywhere and everywhere.
You would hear just a crazy angel cells
are partying story like angel sells.
I always hear of him like that,
that that Mitsis got on their wall,
the store and in Hoya and
he's like in a half shirt,
got off this hair feathered a Bandana,
like roller blades in one
hand and it's just so weird.
I met him once a few years ago when I
was on tour with Charlie Murphy and John
Heffrons. What's he doing? Good guy. He's
still in clubs still, you know? Yeah.
There's those guys man, like go to
long island, go to Long Island and go,
you know like see the guys who are like
thought local long island guys are still
around. They've been around for a long
time. Funny guys to like Joey Cola. Right?
Funny Guy. Just stand up for that long.
Yeah, they just put their, you know,
just sort of,
they stay around sort of on the periphery
for whatever reason the rest of the
world was and find out about them.
It's straight. I don't think, you know,
it's funny,
I don't think I'll ever stop doing standup
regardless of you want to do it for a
lot of people. But I, you know,
stand up is one of those things.
Who has that great philosopher, said
man's never more himself when at play.
I think those angel styles are and
Joe Salazar and the idea, the idea,
I say shake it out,
but the idea is when I'm not on the road,
when I'm not doing stand up,
you know,
I really start to miss it so I
can understand that you just,
you do it cause it's when
you're the most authentic.
Maybe you do because you're trying
to get the fuck away from your house.
If you also go to [inaudible] dot com
that's our last sponsor, o. N, n. I. T.
You'll see that although we only have the
chimpanzee tribal bell in Primal Bell,
tribal bill, primal, primal,
tribal, all those douchey words,
we have a new gorilla one coming out.
It's going to be fucking bad ass. Yeah,
it's a 72 pounds. It's sick. It's awesome.
The sculpture is a cool as fuck. And
we've got a few more coming after that.
We're slowly trickle in. The
men, very difficult to make,
very difficult to produce.
Difficult to also because we make
sure they're balanced. Um, the,
the thing is an entirely,
like if you look at a regular kettle bell,
it's very simple. It's very, you
know, to symmetrical shape this,
the circle and then the handle is on it.
It's a nice big thick handle.
They balance it sets in the middle.
But when you have a sculpture
like a chimpanzee, not that easy.
So we had a map it out and design it and
make sure that when you work out with
it, it works exactly like
a regular kettle bell.
And that's the same for
the gorilla one as well.
And then the other ones
we have coming out too,
we had to change faces and redesign
things and move things around.
It's a real pain in the ass, but we wanted
to make sure that they look bad ass.
And there were also functional. They're
going to use my face apparently to,
there's word of that, a million pounds,
what? I heard million pounds, £1 million.
They use them for those bell with my face.
Those Pacific Rim robots,
they're going to train with them. Um,
if you've never used kettlebells before,
I always tell everybody, but I
think it bears repeating. Um,
he got to go to a trainer,
go,
go pay somebody a hundred bucks
or whatever the hell they charge,
and someone who knows what they're doing
and just videotape it and just get them
to go through the basic movements of it.
Start slow.
Don't lift a shitload of weight,
lift lightweights correctly.
I have a 35 pound kettle bell that
chimpanzee kettlebells, 35 pounds.
And I know he would look in a manly man
like myself, and he said, Joe Rogan,
what could you possibly do with 35 pounds,
which you get your tie on the ball with
it or what you can you get exhausted?
Trust me, the one that we
have that we sell and on it,
it's called the Keith Webber
Cardio extreme cardio workout.
And these DVDs that we sell extreme
cardio and extreme to their fucking insane
35 pound cattle.
But I've done them with the 50.
You want to have a goddamn heart
attack. It's insane. It's amazing.
Do it like a 45 pound or how
long is the workout for? Well,
there's a series of workouts. It's
a bunch of workouts. It's like,
it's almost really, how long
can you do it? You know,
it was like a bunch of them that go back
and forth and back and forth, you know,
but the, the, once you start doing reps,
you start doing like windmills and cleans
and presses and over and over and over
again.
It's just unbelievably good as far as
like a strength and conditioning workouts,
the best as far as it.
And it gives you great cardio too and it
gives you functional strength go to on.
And that's o, n n, I, t,
a. As I mentioned, the uh,
the results of the Alpha brain
tests, the um, what do they call it?
Double Blind, double blind placebo
tests, which were very positive,
will be released soon. We're just got
it. We got to get them published. But a,
we're also on a, onto another one
onto another larger tests. Uh,
large scale,
even more expensive test just because you
think it's necessary to make sure that
people don't have any questions about,
you know,
whether or not something's effective.
We don't want any claims of snake oil.
No one's trying to rip you off.
The way we have it set up at on it is all,
all the supplements that you buy,
whether it's shrimp tank or Alpha brain,
the supplements all
have a 30 day or 90 day,
30 pill money back guarantee.
So if you buy the first 30 pills and
within 90 days you say, this is bullshit.
This doesn't do anything for me.
You get 100% of your money back.
You don't even have to
send the product back.
The reason being is because we're sure
that everything that we sell does what it
claims and you're going to
enjoy it. Whether it's new
mood, which is very simple,
scientifically proven,
it's five HTP and improves your
brain's ability to produce serotonin.
You produce more. Um, there's also a El
trip to fan which converts to five HTP.
All that stuff is great for your
mood. That's real. Like there's the,
in fact they tell people who are on Ssri
is to not take five HTP because you can
get too much serotonin.
They tell you to avoid that and just
take their pharmaceutical medication that
seems anything wrong with
farms pharmaceuticals.
But I am saying that you can get a boost
in your mood from taking something like
new mood and it's can't Kate
guaranteed. Um, use a code name,
Rogan and save 10% off any supplements.
Brian counters here and we're
fitting to get busy because we do,
that's what we do. Going hunting again
this November together with Steve Rinella.
We don't fuck around and get the bag
three back in action. Boom. Schelok lock.
Boom.
Here we go.
Experience
wee baby Jesus.
Jesus,
Louisa,
Brian motherfucking Callan.
Also known as by the way,
or the kid.
I refer to myself as as a kid.
Whenever I'm on set now I
make the cameraman, everybody
refers to me as a kid.
Like they're like, if the kid can
you just move to the left? I'm like,
have you been on when you've been doing,
I just did a stint on a movie
called flock of dudes and uh,
that's it.
I've just been doing,
I like to take long the long breaks
between my acting, but I just did a movie.
I did a movie a little bit with the
Elizabeth Banks who's 40 and couldn't look
better. Who's bit banks is. Um,
she sent it in a ton of movies.
I don't know if she's done
the chick from showgirls? No,
that's Elizabeth Perkins or
something. Who knows? But this,
this don't you say who nurse
knows about showgirls? Dude,
just don't actually know her cause I used
to date her friend when I first got to
La. So who were the showgirls? But yeah,
Elizabeth Hurley. No, it's not a reason.
I really don't, don't ever chime in if
you rob Berkeley, Berkeley, Berkeley,
ladies and gentlemen. What a pretty
face and honey, you know. Okay.
Yes. Not, nothing special. Don't
believe she's a dancer. Before we start.
I just want to, can I just, can I just
hawk a date? Yeah. Before we start.
Go ahead.
This weekend at the Schomburg Improv,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday. Brian
Callan, uh, enjoy your fruit compote.
Are Thinking about going there guys
to get too much. It's just too much.
It's too full of energy.
I don't want to deal with that.
I want to be in that presence. Just got
it. I know exactly who you are. You Ready?
Are you ready for hunting again? Dude
back. Here's what I'm worried about. You.
You had to choose November
21st in Wisconsin.
You think the Missouri breaks was
cold in October. We're going to fail.
It's going to be cold. Why are you
such a pussy? Because I am a plus.
I've got a long neck and I can't
conserve heat. That's why we're close.
I remember short neck and wide, wide
center of gravity. You retain heat.
We were freezing on that boat and you
come by me and you were like, Hey,
you had icicles on your beard and
you were smiling at me. I was like,
what are you smiling? I grew up in Boston
and I know how to deal with the heat.
Oh, I know how to deal with the
cold. Rather you just deal with it.
He's just deal with it. You just
accept it. Are we sleeping? Oh No, no.
Not this time. I'm going to
sleep in the cabin. Really? Yeah.
We're going to have like, it's going
to be like a real place. We can.
You have a bed? The whole
deal. Everything's going to
be beautiful. I can't wait.
We're gonna have a good time.
That's no problem.
Then we're going to have a good time.
Don't be a pussy. No, I'm going to be fun.
I get to keep your live there.
Those people live there all year round.
It's from Wisconsin. They fun. Yeah,
I've talked to in the north woods.
I bet you have. Yeah. I really have. You
been to Chicago in January? I sure have.
I've done a few gigs in
Chicago in January. That's,
Ooh. Ooh. They don't play.
Don't play around with that.
They don't play around with that.
I just got back from Alaska. You did?
Yeah. I went salmon fishing up there.
I didn't tell you about that.
Ari should fear and I went up there.
You know already that outdoorsman you
should fear. It can hang. I can hang.
I bet he can. He can. He finds his way
through. Right? He's a smart motherfucker.
Yeah. He knows how to do anything
he wants to do. That's what it is.
He gets good at anything. He wants to
get good at it and it's just, you know,
he's the real deal. Well, what did you,
did you catch any salmon? Yes. You know,
I went to Alaska and went and
fishing. Did you really? Yes.
You turning this around on your slide
caught nothing. So I'm asking you a few.
I literally caught nothing.
Oh. And by the way,
we spent $600 to take a go
deep sea fishing. Me and my
father, guess who got sick?
Both of us were like, Hey, can
we turn this boat around? Yeah.
You going to hear about,
you're just kind of go with a guide
and then you get salmon. That pig. Oh,
what is that dinosaur? What is
that? The 40 pounds. Salmon.
Yeah.
We caught a ton of them.
We caught seven of them one day
and then another day we caught,
we caught four and I caught a wild
rainbow trout to now did you catch them as
they were coming to die? Uh, yes.
Yes. I mean essentially they're there.
They don't live, you know, they, they come
back up, they spawn. And that's a wrap
son. Did you see anything going on?
You see any bear? We did not. We
saw eagles, so a lot of eagles,
but we are on the lookout for bear
saw a five Mousse inside of two days.
Moose are everywhere up there.
It's amazing. They're also,
they say way more dangerous
than a lot of animals. Oh yeah.
We saw it by the way too,
by the way, by the way, I,
the way we saw two of the Moose
had babies with them twice.
So out of the four we saw two mamas and
two babies in two completely different
areas.
So those are the most dangerous.
When you see a mother with her baby and
we saw a mother with her baby on a tiny
island. Our friend Matt, who's a, the
guide that we, uh, went out there with,
he took us to his dad as an island
with like a bunch of cabins on it.
We took a boat out to this island and
there's a moose and her baby on the island
and we're like, oh shit, this is a
small ass island. It's like a block.
And the Moose is like, what you're doing
here bitch? And we're like, oh shit.
I guess it's swam there. It's
a horse. Yeah, horse that swam.
You never think of a horse swimming.
They can swim.
They shortly swim like in the middle
of the water, like its deepest fuck.
And they swim right through
it. And by the way, that water,
and if I remember correctly,
even in the summer in the North Atlantic,
you got about 10 minutes, you fall in
that what? You got about 10 minutes?
That's not the Atlanta I fell. That's
the Pacific. That's what I meant.
I meant the Pacific. Don't ever embarrass
me on a podcast like that again,
just to help you get the email,
the email area of the Pacific
that's closest to the Atlantic,
that pub when it's
flipped around real quick,
when it flips around you and your
technical ideas about what a c is, a yeah,
but you got about, I think 10 minutes
to, to live that pleases is so gangster.
It's such a beautiful place to,
if you've been to Alaska, half,
you got to do stand up
there. Really? Fuck yes.
It's one of the greatest places in
the world where anchorage, I'll go,
you gotta go gotta go.
It's amazing. First of all,
these people are cool as shit.
All right. Yeah. They're like,
they're like the coolest people
like from Portland or boulder,
like those kinds of people except
to live in the Pacific. I mean,
as far up there as you can get, you know,
skip and a jump away from Russia. Yeah.
I mean, they're way the fuck up
there. Past Canada, it's cold as fuck.
It was three o'clock in the morning when
we were leaving the bar and it's bright
out. Wow. Yeah. It's weird. I mean
when we went out there it was actually,
the temperature was nice.
It was in the 70s the mosquitoes
are unfucking relenting. Oh yeah.
Relently you've never seen anything
like it. It's like they know they don't,
they only have a certain amount of time,
so like you get out of your car and
there's a hundred of them on you in your
face within seconds. It's
incredible. They swarm you.
One person with malaria in, in Alaska
could kill the entire state. Yeah.
They would just spread like wildfire
through these fucking cutty mosquitoes
there.
Unbelievable.
Like you've never seen anything like it
and get out of your car. It's a cloud of,
I'm just, I don't think off works with
those guys. It works. It does. Yeah.
Ddt, we used a whatever shit we
they bought, we bought it at Rei.
You know it works.
It works great. It's, you need it. You
need, it probably gives you cancer, right?
I mean,
who knows the fight.
They might be worth it though when
you got a cloud of mosquitoes. Yeah.
Believe me, I was in Utah last week
and I didn't use it in time. Now I got,
I got bites all over my arms,
those cold areas while I was in Indonesia
and I had to carry a sulfur coil.
You don't, oh by the way, uh, the way, by
the way, you, when you're in Indonesia,
at least don't think
that you're going to use,
please don't think that office is going
to work because those tropical bugs
scoff at it. They laugh at it too, that
I had to carry a sulfur coil and burn it.
And that's what kept the mosquitoes
away from you. Is that real?
How does off not work? Uh,
because they're just too,
they don't care. They're tropical
mosquitoes and tropical bugs.
So we would carry a sulfur
coil and you burn a sulfur.
Could you hold it in your hand and you
burn it as you walk? How about that?
And that's what keeps them elicit work.
Yeah.
How well does and it and cause we would
you track in the middle of the like when
I was still dark and then you set up a
hammock cause you don't wanna sleep on
the floor cause bugs will get
you so you can set up a hammock.
You lie in a Hammock,
you wait for the orangutan above you to
wake up now when you're in and then when
the whole forest wakes up,
it's louder than grand central station.
It's just you never heard anything
like in my life and your life.
Do the forest in the tropical
rain forest a louder than I put,
put me on the corner of
42nd and fifth avenue.
It's louder and I'm not exaggerating at
all. Is it mostly bugs or is it bugs?
Birds, monkeys, all together
just squawking different
crickets, different, you know,
grass, whatever it is. Create.
Just when the whole forest
wakes up you're like,
this is the craziest thing
I've ever heard in my life.
I mean monk but birthday and you're
just like, are you kidding me?
And it's mostly the bugs.
It's mostly the different bugs
that are doing weird things.
Like rubbing their license
together are, or frogs, you know,
that are woo, you know, and
I just couldn't believe it.
And you better carry a software coil.
User freaked me out.
When you told me about your
first experiences there,
when back when you were thinking about
being like a bug scientist because, uh,
you told me about the posts
that they had on the, the,
where you slept and you had to
cover them with turpentines, right.
Because of the ants, the
ants, when they're foraging,
what they'll do is they'll tell,
just crawl over you. No problem.
If they're hunting,
you better have tournament time on
those posts because they'll find you,
they'll come up those posts, you're
in your, you know, tent or you're,
you're in your bed and
they'll come and kill you.
They'll come and eat you and you
can hear them, you can hear them.
There's so many of them that you can
hear a weird sort of hum. So, uh,
that's what I'm walking.
Yeah.
Apparently you can hear them when they're
on the march when there, you know,
millions of them in their hunting.
You can hear the movement of
the ground or whatever it is.
As they move, as they forage
through, it actually makes a sound
to this.
Millions of people don't understand.
This is a real fact that the weight of
human beings is equal to the weight of
ants in the entire world.
Yeah.
Just think about how many ants
it would take to equal a person.
How many millions of ants it was.
You'd have to stack right on top of each
other to equal the weight of a normal
person. Well, the,
there's an equal number of pounds in
the world of human as there are of an,
well, I, I got to my mind really blown
it. I had a guy on my podcast recently,
James Rollins, who is a like a, right?
He's like that Michael Crighton and he,
he went and spoke to some
mathematicians at NASA and the latest,
um, they, they had all
these really weird theories,
which is we're basically living
in a hologram. The [inaudible].
Have you heard about this? Oh yeah. Yeah.
It's, it's a blue my, then they said,
then they said no. He said, well,
what do you mean? He said, well,
if you were to take all the Ma,
all the space out of
the atoms were made of.
So if you take all the space, so he
took all the electrons pro, you know,
whatever that surrounds the nucleus.
If you put it all together,
you could take every human
being that's ever lived, the Ma,
the actual mass that we're made
of and put it into a baseball.
So then it raises the question of what
in the world is holding us together?
We're, I, if you look closely enough,
we are way more space and,
and what seems to be creating solid
matter is the relationship between,
uh, energy fields. There's no way
that they, as they look closer,
there's no way they can actually point
to like what we're touching right now.
Like this wood, it's really, it's
just, it's mind blowing. Like,
what are you talking about? Like
I, when he said that, he goes,
you could take every human being
has ever lived in. If you put,
if you actually took what
they're really made of,
the matter that the atoms are made up,
you could put it into a baseball, what,
stop it. Every human being. Yes. He went
to all this. Like he just did this pilot,
did the buckets.
He went through all,
all of this crazy stuff he
was talking to them about.
Yeah.
I had a guy from JPL,
this Dr. Richard Terrell,
and uh,
he was, uh, talking to me about,
uh, about simulation theory.
Tetell Terrell, I can't read this. Um,
he was talking to me about simulation
theory and he was talking to me about the
exponential growth,
who computers that literally the amount
of computations per second that the,
uh, the computers did the
largest computers back when
the Apollo Moon landing
program was going on.
The Mount of computations per second that
they were capable of is the same as a
key fob on a car
that's so vine boggling how,
where were going fucking beyond and saying
a key fob on a car is actually fast.
So crazy. It moves fast, stir
it makes more computations per
second then that giant computers.
It's not capable of the same thing,
but as far as computations per second,
your cell phone,
certainly as your cell phones of far
more far more than any computer back then
did, which was the size of our
room, you know, and they were,
what we're talking about is
one of the episodes of this,
a new show that I'm doing, which premieres
tomorrow on Scifi Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
One of the subjects is the subject of
simulation theory about how insane it is
that you can one day rest assure
without a doubt 100% they will create an
artificial reality that is indiscernible
from the reality that you're
experiencing right now. There's
not a goddamn doubt about it. Not,
not 1000000th of 1% doubt that
if human being stay alive,
if we don't blow ourselves up, get killed
in a pandemic or hit by an asteroid,
if any of those things don't happen,
then within x amount of years fill,
fill in the blanks,
whether it's a hundred a thousand,
there's going to be a time
where the computation power,
the ability to manipulate neurons is
going to be at a level that you are going
to be able to insert an rd Fishel world
into someone's mind and then you're not
going to be able to know whether or not
you're in that mind or whether you are
in the real world. Are you
in an artificial world or
are you in the real world?
But here,
here's where it gets really freaky.
What if you're in the artificial world
and inside that artificial world you
create an artificial world.
That's where things get fractal,
which is essentially the nature
of the entire universe itself.
When you boil things down, when
you, when you get really small,
things get really big.
You know,
and when you're talking about all
the air that's inside of an atom,
you know all the space inside of the atom.
Well that sounds a whole lot like
the whole universe, doesn't it?
Doesn't that sound like a chair? It
does. Yeah. A mini, it's a mini universe.
Every galaxy is essentially,
and look at the distance between galaxies
and you look at galaxies and you look
at them and they like,
they look like stars because
they're so small and so far away.
But you see how far there is
between them and the next galaxy.
And then you realize that that little
small dot you're looking at is actually
probably three or 400 billion stars,
including a supermassive black
hole in the center of it.
That's one half of 1% of the
mass of the entire galaxy.
And they go on forever. And there's this
massive amount of space. But I mean,
this is essentially a giant Adam.
It really is almost the same thing.
There's that theory that everything,
whether it's the sal,
a red blood cell or a skin
cell or you know, we are all,
it's all essentially, um, many universes.
They all mirror each other
on smaller levels. So,
so you've got the whole universe
and then if you look at a self,
you actually get into the minutia of a
cell and really look at everything that's
going on. It's every bit as complicated
as everything around us. It's,
it's just a mini version of that.
So we are reflections,
different levels of reflections of the
exact same thing just on smaller or
larger scales,
which is why the concept of creating a
simulation and inside that simulation,
creating a simulation is so fucking
nuts. It's like you're, they,
the real problem comes when what you
can simulate is exactly the same as what
you can experience outside of the
simulation than which one is which. Right.
And why is there a difference? What
says who so cause you can knock on it.
Well guess what? You can knock on it
when you're in there too. So it's real.
Then when it becomes real,
this guy,
James Rollins was again saying that they
were also talking about strength theory,
the parallel universes,
right.
The notion that there are different
realities right next to each other.
And maybe that's exactly what what it is.
That's where the Hologram,
this weird idea that, I can't remember
how he was describing it, but he, he, um,
she's got the buck as a,
but he was,
he was talking about how
there is like this, um,
it's like a third sort of, well,
it's basically a hologram. Basically.
The idea that there's a, there's
a riff, the, um, uh, this,
what we're seeing here is just a
reflective reality of something else.
That's something I don't, I don't
know. I don't even have, it's too hard.
I can't too stupid to actually repeat
what these people have their lives too.
It's like so rude to get it. Oh Man.
It's just like a whole, you know,
like the fuck it's, it. No,
it's not Jesus that did my
doctorate in that. You fuck.
It's, um, it's, it's so
incredibly complicated, but it's,
thank God someone's doing that work.
What do you know what, he blew me away.
He said that the Greeks had kind of
had this assumption, had this thought.
It was like a theory. So like in ancient
Greece, like this is not a new theory.
The idea that you're creating your own
universe in your mind and that you live
inside of some artificial
play that's being, well it's
what in in fact it's, it's,
it's Plato's allegory of the cave and
the idea that we live in a cave and
reality for most of us is
simply reflections on the wall.
It's, it's, uh, it, that's exactly what
this Holly man that God was saying. So,
so Plato's allegory of the cave is
that we are all in the dark and we,
what we think is real is
actually just just a, um, uh,
superimposed images, imagery on a, on a,
on a cave wall and where
you have to get out of that,
you have to climb up and follow the
light and then come back and tell people
about it. But that, that's
the allegory of the cave,
which is everything is
basically, um, forms. Uh, there,
there is the notion that you can,
you can, you may not know like the,
um, the idea is that you may not be
able to draw a perfect triangle. Okay.
It would always be off a little bit
even if you had all the instruments,
but you can imagine a perfect triangle.
You can imagine it.
And so the idea is that for, I
got another great example is, um,
this blew my fucking mind.
You have a mathematician,
he's 175 years ago,
comes out of a dark room and says,
I just came up with a
mathematical equation. Uh, by
the way, it's 300 pages long.
Uh, it has zero relevance to
the world and Oh, by the way,
I'm going to die now.
See Ya dies.
And here's this equation is
sitting there 175 years later.
Some guys measuring the difference between
like the relationship between quarks
and how it relates to this
and how it relates to,
and they're trying to make a gyroscope
at NASA or something or some kind of a
telescope. And they go,
Hey, guess what? This guy,
this mathematician 175 years ago,
came up with this mathematical equation.
What we're working on right now,
that mathematical equation is very
relevant to this physical reality.
So this guy has a dream,
comes up with a mathematical equation
that 175 years later bears physical
reality that we're using in our
cell phone or we're using, you know,
in a telescope or whatever it is.
It takes on a physical reality.
So whatever this guy imagined 175 years
ago in his mind for whatever reason was
put there and is used 175 years later
for something very physical and the
physical world. It's weird man. And he's
like, why was it, why? What happened?
Why did that guy think of that?
He was able to imagine a reality that
had no bearing on the world today and the
hundred 75 years later it
did. That's, that's where I
get really kind of, I'm not,
I'm doing a shitty job of explaining it.
I know what you're saying.
W W we,
we'll you're basically saying is that
someone had an insight into the way things
work that no one else had achieved before.
And he was so far ahead that no one
could figure it out till 175 years later,
somebody revisited.
But it was also more than insight.
It was actually a physical,
measurable reality.
And he proved on paper
[inaudible] mathematically
somebody measuring the inside
of a conch shell or,
and how it relates to a beehive spires
or whatever and all of a sudden goes,
this mathematical equation is exactly is,
is proving my theory.
It's measuring what I'm using for
this particular physical reality.
You know what that is?
It's a great example of why we need
different kinds of people in this world.
We need it. We need a goddamn
broad spectrum. Damn right dude.
I was watching this Joey Diaz video today.
Uh,
Ari Shaffir has this new thing on
comedy central.com. It's called.
This is not happening and it's all
people just telling the most fucked up
stories. It's like standup comics but
telling like insane stories of their life.
And Joey Diaz told one
about being on heroin,
about doing heroin and doing drugs for
years. And it was so fucking funny.
And I was sitting there watching it and
I was thinking thank God there's guys
like Joey Diaz out there to not just
so I could laugh and be around them and
have fun, but so that I'd
know what this stuff is like.
I don't want to do heroin.
Okay, I'm not going to do it.
It's not on the menu. Okay,
he's your, he's your getting paid. But
when you talk to a guy that's done heroin,
as much as Joey has done coke as much
as joy and he has these great stories
about it and the, and the harrowing
Harwin feelings of, of, of addiction
that he can relay to you
without you having hack ever
hack actually having to do
them. Right. So important. And it's also
important to have mathematicians. Yeah,
cause I'm not fucking,
you give me that big pile of paper.
You might as well have given
that to a chimp. Oh, of course.
And I ain't going nowhere. Of course it's
for, it's not, I don't have the time.
I'm going to be beaten off. I'm going to
take naps. I'm going to want to work out.
I'm going to look at my
biceps in the mirror. Me Too.
I to get up and eat all the time.
I'm going to go play pool.
I'm going to watch TV. I'm not
going to do that. I'm pretty,
I'm pretty disciplined, but I'm only
discipline with shit I like to do. Right.
I'm disciplined with Jujitsu.
I'm do discipline with working out.
I'm just spent with doing comedy with
work. I like doing those things though,
so it's not really disciplined. The real
discipline is trying to do math. Yeah.
That's fucking desk.
Especially math theory where you're
thinking up these really these crazy
theorems that, that don't have
any numbers. Even numbers.
It's like letters and and weird
equations and and you're, you're,
you're following some thread that
then you know, the answer is,
and the answer is 170 pages long and
somebody out there and about the match.
Mathematicians go, brilliant. Well
guess what? Russian guy that found the,
the imposter theory.
If these seven pages long and
they wanted to give $1 million,
it's like I don't want that money. Right,
because he said, I'm, I'm actually,
you're giving, you're giving me the
money. I'm just the radio transmitter.
I was just, all I did was channel
it. It was always out there.
Give it to the theorem in the sky.
I just happened to have been,
I have a certain wiring that was
able to channel the the equation.
What was funny about that,
if I'm, if I'm not mistaken,
is they didn't actually even
know if the question was valid.
They didn't even know what
the, the, they didn't,
there was a theory out there that that
was actually a legitimate math theorem.
Our question like they didn't even know
if that was something you should even,
you were able to think about.
They didn't know if it a reality to
think about and he was like, yes it is,
or the more here's the answer. Well
there's Dan is more proof that there's,
there's, it's so important to
have a broad spectrum of people.
It's very important.
I mean,
you and I are not going to build a good
house if we don't have an architect.
If we don't have a carpenter,
we're going to do a shit job.
We're going to make a tent.
We're going to make some shitty lean to,
and we're just going to have to deal
with that until we dig up some books that
some smart people figured
out on how to make a house,
but it goes back to what I was saying
about the allegory of the cave.
You may not be able to achieve perfection,
but you can imagine perfection you,
you may not be able to
achieve that Theorem,
but that theorem can still
inspire something else in
you and that that in itself
is where we are connected.
That in itself is why other
people have tremendous value.
If you open yourself up to those kinds
of people, I always say that you you,
it's very important for young people.
I always talk about this and we don't
live in a world that fosters this.
We live in a world that's very
much about what you, your appetite,
how does this affect me specifically?
It's very important I think, to, to,
to expose yourself to things that
force you to reach beyond yourself.
That's where, um, somebody who does
something that has nothing to do with you,
but learning about it or at least being
inspired by how difficult it might be.
It could be opera, could be some great
piece of art that you don't understand.
That's not a bad thing to get involved in
or at least read about because it will,
it can,
it not only does it force you to kind
of to go beyond your own experience,
but I think it, you never know
how it's going to inspire you.
You don't know how it's what it's
going to spark inside of you. For me,
I derive a great deal of inspiration
from just being awed by that,
which I don't understand. Yeah. I
love to go see shit I can't do like,
that's one of the reasons why I
like to go see musicians. You know,
I love to go see live music cause I
have zero talent. I have zero talent,
zero desire, zero ability.
Like I know some Comedians,
I really wish they were rock stars.
I've never had a fucking single second
where I thought about being a singer in a
band or playing music,
musical instrument if you want.
Are you going to be in
Florida next? I Dunno. Okay.
There's a group called the flyers and
this kid named Patrick for readiness.
He plays a guitar and I'm, I'm just
gonna. I mean, if you're in Florida,
if you're a find this guy
Patrick freeness and the flyers,
he plays a guitar better than any,
I've never seen anything like
it. And by the way, I've been,
I was with music and say anymore by
the ways I'm done. What's happened?
You have no more, by the way. Okay. For
the show. The last, by the way. All right,
well just remind me, remind me. I wanna,
I wanna I wanna die every time we do it,
we say, do I keep saying that?
I don't, I don't hear myself.
He, he plays a guitar so well that I
was with other musicians and they, he,
he jumped out for a guest spot and they,
these two guitars came up to me and
they were like, I've never seen,
I've been playing the guitar in my
whole life and I have to photo my,
what's his name? Patrick Farinas. He goes,
I've never seen any like does he
have any things online? Not Online.
How's it possible? He's not what it
should be on. How old is he? 30 well,
how can we haven't heard of him because
he and I talked to him about it. He, he,
he's now doing original music before he
was doing a lot of cover stuff and now
he's doing, and I said, you've
got a responsibility bro,
which is you've got to start doing,
you've got to start doing
your own original expression
because it's one thing to
be technically brilliant, end
to db. Any empathize within it.
I mean he also improvisers. I mean,
dude, he does. He Act, he, he'll,
he'll do an amalgam, he'll do like
a composite set where you're just,
you're just like, what in the
world is he doing with the guitar?
There was something wrong with like
doing a little bit of cover band action,
like a few cover songs,
but that's a real trap for young bands
that want to perform in bars and make a
living because people don't want to
hear your fucking original songs for the
most part, especially as like background
music, whether trying to get laid,
you know, they want to hear
sweet home Alabama. That's right.
Saying it pitch right.
We don't want to hear my time on the lake.
But you get to a point when you,
when you reach physical mastery
like this guy has and, and,
and he's gotten beyond that.
He's very innovative with the guitar.
It's not like he's, he's not copying
clapped and he's doing his own thing.
There's a big difference though
between that and writing your own
music cause a difference.
It's like the ability to tell a joke,
you know that you stole from someone and
the ability to write a joke like that
yourself. We can all name a few people
that can't do one of those things.
We all know if you guys that are really
successful that have made a career at a
ripping off other people's ideas because
the fact they can't do both. Right.
This is the dude right here. Oh,
there is? Yeah. Looking at watch.
He's shredding does. She does the craziest
things on the guitar. That's one thing.
That's how that Joe Satriani type shit.
Right?
I like to use fat too. He's, he's lost
weight now, but he's having a monster.
He's a monster. He's playing guitar
with his face right now, folks. Yeah.
That's this guitar playing you're hearing
right now is with this dude's mouth.
That's pretty crazy. Yeah. He's
a nut. I've never seen any lives
Lorida.
Yep.
It's weird that that seems to be the
only good thing that comes out of Florida
is occasionally they have some good
musicians. Yup. Everything else sucks.
I shouldn't my, I have family
members that lived there. Folks.
I love people in Florida. Don't get me
wrong, my actual parents live in Florida,
but let's be honest. Let's be
honest. Let's be honest. Let's see.
Grace. Yeah. Nancy grace was starved
to death if it wasn't for Florida.
All right, Richard. I remember
talking about barely, but you know,
it's like they came up like Skinner came
out of Florida has been some good bands
out of Florida, but like name a good
comedian that came out of Florida. Yeah,
I'm waiting. I know. I don't know. I guess
Tom Rhodes did. Tom Rhodes come on. Flora.
I feel like Tom Roads are all
in there. Yeah, I think, yeah,
Tom Rhodes is from Orlando.
I just appreciate comedy or a
musical instrument or anything.
It takes a really long time to get
good at it. Yeah. I had a buddy,
I had a buddy that, uh, I got to dance
around this without giving out any names.
I have a buddy that, um, you
know, during the 80s, especially,
standup comedy was pretty fucking wild.
Okay.
There was zero accountability. There
was, um, there was no emailing.
There was no, I mean, people got coked
up and they did some wild shit and you,
you basically,
it was just a story you didn't have
to worry about someone like Facebook
picturing you tied up with a fucking a
hundred Dick's stuffed in your mouth,
good old days. But, um,
there was a woman that was like
working at a comedy club, uh,
like a manager of a comedy club.
My friend went down there to
perform and fell in love, you know,
and then started living down
there in Florida, but then
it turns out, as you know,
he was there for a little while. He
started, uh, people were like, Hey, uh,
can I talk to me for a second, pull them
aside. And they were like, just, you know,
I would want to endow this,
what I'm going to tell you so I'm going
to tell you and just do it just to come
in and town. Just run
terrains on her. And she was,
she was famous for like guys tying
or rob and like all their friends,
just, just fucking her face taking
pictures of it. And there it is.
It was just complete total chaos.
Like no,
I mean she was a total wild woman and
then this poor fuck came into town.
And uh, she winked at him and
gave him a hug and he was in love.
And so he moved there, you know,
and a crushed him devastate him.
Devastated his life. Cause he
married this woman. Yes he did. Yes.
And then he re along the way is sort of
like unfollowing like guys would come
into town and you know,
they had,
they had been running trains on her
for the last 10 years, you know,
when she was managing this club. So turned
out I got, what can we, are we partying,
which like I'm married now and they
were like, what the fuck you're married.
Like everybody was like, just
no way. That's not possible.
Like how's that possible?
And so eventually she went back to her
wild ways and uh, cause he divorced her.
No, well no, in the middle, you know,
like almost right away she went right
back to it. I mean while she was,
and so it didn't. So this poor
guy, I can't say any names.
This poor guy who was a friend, I really
liked the guy and we came up together.
We were in Boston, we were open microscan
either and he had some real potential.
But it's amazing how a devastating
breakup can affect people in such an
incredible way that they
emotionally never recover from it.
And it's one of the reasons why,
in my opinion,
it's so important to get children
involved in competitive athletics and
competitive things.
So they learn how to lose things.
They learn how to lose games.
You learn how to lose relationships.
He learned how to lose things.
Losing things is important.
Expectations that don't come
through all that stuff. Well,
it's also important to know that you
can bounce back when you've bounced back
before you understand about bouncing back.
But when you've only experienced
fear and then insecurity,
and then the devastating feeling of
loss compound ever want that again?
No,
you orchestrate your life so you never
fail again and you'll never take a chance
and never take a chance again. And you
also have to have friends. Those are,
those are, those are important
aspects, like a loner who gets dumped.
Those are the guys that put guns in
their mouth. You also need a mentor.
You need someone who's been through it
before. That's where a coach comes in,
so to help you navigate, not a
coach, a buddy of a group of friends,
a whole bunch of for sure,
but there's also, when you,
when you are trying to get
really good at something,
a lot of times you have somebody older
who can help you navigate through the
plateaus for sure that that's why I
just put your attention on something.
I don't give a shit what it has taken
action because there's always a lesson
there. It's almost like the
thing in and of itself is,
is less important than what you learn
by trying to get good at it. In a way.
It's also because these things
like breakups and these,
these devastating events
that can happen to a person,
they don't get treated with the proper
respect by the people that are raising
you. They get treated like, oh, someone
broke your heart. You're going to be fine.
Like it's not that
simple. Okay? You're you,
what you're dealing with is an
incredible shift in the emotional state.
And if this person does not
know how to navigate that shift,
they don't know how to
get out of that situation.
It can be a motherfucker getting
your ass kicked can do that to you.
You know? Um, being
humiliated can do that too.
You remember Kerry at
the, at the PR, the Prom,
and they just pour the blood on her
head and she just fucking goes crazy and
people start flying through the
walls and shit. But that's real,
that feeling that you can get when
people are angry at you or hate you,
that, that feeling, that horrific
feeling when you bomb. How about that?
Some guys bomb and they literally want
to go to the hotel room and slice their
risk.
I've seen,
I've seen three comics with great
potential do really well their first time,
do really well the second time
and obviously like standup,
they get up and try to do the same thing
with another crowd and they die because
it wasn't their friends.
They never do stand up again.
It's like they have potential
and they have great potential,
but they never do it again. You
know, this friend of mine, it was a,
an early lesson about what can happen.
I had some good early lessons.
I had a real nice girlfriend in high
school. She was a very, very nice person.
Like she was, she was not
mean at all, but you know,
when you're 14 years old, relationships
don't really last. And you know,
from her went on to other ones and uh,
one of the other ones,
um, I dated this girl
that was just, you could,
you could roll a dick
by her like a kitten.
Like you could roll a ball of yarn
by a kitten. They just jump on it.
That's what this girl was like. This is
the girlfriend, her girlfriend. Yeah,
she's pretty too.
And she couldn't help herself.
I mean, I, I just,
I've seen people that can help themselves
and I've seen people that can't,
this girl could not help herself. She
was, first of all, it was Catholic.
She was raised in Catholic
school and they, you know,
they suppressed the shit out of her.
Right.
They make you wear this one fucking
outfit and the suppressor shit out of you.
And psychologically like all you
had to do was get this girl alone,
like any guy could get this girl alone.
And that was a wrap. It was over. Yeah.
Yeah.
She was crazy.
And I didn't really even find out how
crazy she wasn't until after we stopped
dating and then she would tell me stories
like we worked together and she told
me stories about this new guy she was
dating and how she liked him to smack her
and he would beat her up and she liked it.
She was like,
I don't know what to do cause I like it.
It was just like it was the car.
She was so crazy.
Right.
I mean so it completely lowered
my expectations of loss.
Like I came home one day and uh,
I didn't actually come home.
I was getting up in the morning
cause I had a paper route cause um,
I delivered newspapers for a job
for a long time. Many, many, many,
many, many years. All throughout high
school. Like as soon as I could drive,
there was like one of my first
jobs and while I was fighting,
it was one of my jobs because I could
make a couple hundred bucks a week.
All I had to do was get up in the
morning by like 5:00 AM delivering my
newspaper route and then I'd come back
home and go right back to sleep again.
So I did that for a long ass time and
I would have to get up really early on
Sunday morning.
Essentially it would be Saturday night.
So Saturday night at four o'clock in
the morning, that's when I would be up.
And um,
outside my house is my friend and this
girl and he's fingering her in the front
seat.
Oh yeah.
She was crazy.
God girl was crazy. Oh, that's, so I
slammed my hand on the hood and I go,
ah. And they're like, you know,
like I was laughing at them and
then I got my car, I drove away.
I didn't say a word and I didn't talk
to her for like a week, you know.
But I mean it was, it was, she was not
my girlfriend at the time. It was a girl.
She,
that time she was a girl I was dating,
I should be really clear.
Like I don't think there was ever a time
when we were like officially boyfriend
and girlfriend. We were just dating the
whole time because she was crazy. You
know what helped me a lot.
It was crazy to what helped me a lot.
Navigate loss and things is actually
movies. A good movie. Yeah. Like uh,
like say it again, let know
like rocky, like rocky and
stuff. When I was wrestling,
I remember like you think about the study,
any that's a great movie by the way.
No, it's fine. You think of
the seminary, I loved it.
But you think of these seminal
moot moments in your life.
And I remember I was
signed up for, I was, uh,
I went to boarding school because my
family was still in Saudi Arabia and I'm
like alone there.
And I signed up for jogging cause I
was too afraid to sign up for wrestling
because I had done judo before that I
was like, ah, these guys are too tough.
So inside of a jogging,
this kid,
Gary Lane had seen me put some kid
in a headlock and he goes, hey.
And he drags me over to the
wrestling mat and I just signed up.
And next thing I know I was wrestling
and I wonder what I'd be if I hadn't,
you know, been a wrestler.
It changed my whole life.
But the idea of like when I would,
when I would lose at something,
I remember like I would think back to my
heroes in movies like rocky or whatever
and just, and it just, the
example of if you lose,
keep trying and you'll win in the end.
It was always that feeling.
I think that in that sense, that's where
art or, or movies can play a big role in,
in your life. Man. Yeah.
But it could also give you some bullshit
idea that that white guy could really
beat up that black guy.
Come on.
Don't ruin rocky for me, Bro. For Real.
Five foot 860 pound man, it's really
the heavyweight champion of the world,
by the way. That's exactly
right. He was 155 pounds when he,
when he did rocky. Let's really that
light. Yeah. How do you know that?
That's what I read a long time ago.
People lie about shit.
It's not a big frame guy right
now. He is, he looks big.
But his body was, if you look at it was
10 I use of growing, bring up a rocky,
uh, for when he fought Drago. Take a look
at this frame. You can see his legs thin.
Well,
which you really should put up his,
him at 66 years old.
There's a picture I put on
my Twitter the other day.
Did you see what Geraldo did?
No.
Geraldo Rivera put a picture of himself,
a naked essentially with
his, uh, his, his towel,
like barely over his cock and
it said like 70 is the new 50.
Is Geraldo seven years old? Yes, he's
seven years old and he looks really good.
Let me see a picture of place. It's
all over the Internet. And he pulled,
what's really funny is he took it down,
he put the picture up and then he
decided, it was like, you know, I dunno,
it's two to move to embarrassing.
Fucked up. You know, look at that.
Look at that picture. He's
awesome. He looks great.
Look at that picture, man. He's
still got that awesome mustache. Oh,
the mustache is a motherfucker.
Look at that. And he boxed. He was,
I think it was kind of a good feedback.
I pulled his cock out and it was holding
his knuckles up and going outside like
karate chop hand forward
towards you with his fat cock.
You would be nervous if you,
if you broke it,
that guy's House and his Cock was
oiled up and he was knuckles up.
Just just pulling it in your direction.
You would jump drop your gum and jump out
of Lens for an image I've never had in
my head. Did you have that image? Look,
look at how low it keeps the towel.
Like you insane bastard. He's great.
He looks great though. Seven years old.
Light skin. First of all he looks like
he's about 8% body fat. I mean seriously,
look at all the striations at his chest.
Obviously works hard.
He's in incredible shape.
No doubt.
But I don't know why he didn't keep it
up there. Fuck all those people, man.
Let them get crazy. And you had 70 are
allowed to do that at 70 that's fantastic.
You're not, you're not. If
you're a man, if you're a woman,
you're allowed to do that at any age.
A woman can do that at any age.
You know why? Because we want
to see it. Cause put a man,
no woman wants to see that and no
man wants to see. Yeah, so it's a,
it's a dark corner.
It's like women are not,
I guess it's probably like a few 60 year
olds that are like, I still can get wet.
No. I heard somebody say one time
the difference in men and women,
somebody said it was describing.
I said,
women look really good static and men
look really good when they're doing what
they're good at.
Like so when they're moving,
when there's movement playing a guitar,
just kicking the soccer
ball and maybe it's not,
I don't think it's really a
visual thing as much with women.
Certainly an aspect of it, which is why,
you know really handsome men do well,
I mean there's the,
the facial features and everything that
the Senate Fibonacci sequence. Yeah,
the symmetry of the face and that's,
that's super important to people.
But for women, there's all these other
variables to personality, sense of humor,
the ability to take care of yourself.
Look at Stallone at 66 stop it
shut to shut the fuck up man.
Are you kidding me?
That's insane.
The inside black and sponge lights
his entire inside of his body.
It's like it's waiting to make its
way to the surface of his skin.
I want what he's on and I
don't care what anybody says.
And when you look that good at
66 he, I, I'm very impressed.
That's my Canarian Nicole
on. Yeah, no kidding. Here's,
here's the other thought about that.
Like um,
people look to what were the negative
side effects? Um, you're 66. Okay.
That's the negative side effect.
The negative side effect is being 66 no
matter what negative side effects that
drugs have shit on death.
Okay.
Cause death is the ultimate
negative side effect of life itself.
And it comes a certain point in time.
We're death becomes inevitable.
Whether it's at 66 or whether it's at
86 you cannot have a physique like that
and less you incorporate science
into your diet. Oh, okay.
Not getting that from just doesn't exist.
Lifting weights and eat and nothing
existed. 66 it exists at 30.
There's 30 year old guys that are
built like that that have never touched
hormones,
never done anything.
There's guys that are in their
forties that it looked fantastic,
that have never fucked with
anything unhealthy in their life.
Never done a steroid,
never supplemented their testosterone,
never done anything but
eat good and work hard,
but at 50 and then 66
and they don't exist.
They don't exist. You can't
look like that. You know,
you know what's on the horizon for
hormones? Oh fuck yes. I do. What Tom?
Not only do I know what's
on the horizon for hormones,
hormones are this just one
aspect of the human body.
The most fascinating conversation that
I had recently for the show, um, was a,
I got a chance to talk to Ray Kurzweil.
Oh my God. Did you really? Yeah,
I interviewed him for over an hour. He's
great. He's, first of all, he's a sweetie.
He's a really nice guy.
Like kind easy to communicate with.
Intelligent. There is, there's us
together. Oh my God. Great Guy. Um,
but what he was talking about was these
new innovations in modern science and
medical science that are going to allow
people to literally have super human
abilities out of the gate.
Nanobots stuff. Yeah.
You're going to have a real problem
with like shit like the Olympics when a
person like you can take a shot and
then all of a sudden you have these like
artificial blood cells that are a
million times more effective. He said,
you are literally going to be able to
hold your breath and jumping. No, no, no.
Four hours.
Jump into the bottom of the pool and hold
your breath for four hours on a single
breath. Yeah. Four fucking hours, man.
That's in the singularity is near.
Yeah, that's, but when the guy
says it to you, to your face. Yeah.
And you know a lot
fucking smarter than you.
It's like one of those
like what did we up for?
What's comments about how they reverse
engineered the red blood cell of a dog
and they're doing that with a human red
blood cell and now they're going to take
a Nano Bot and two, they're going to copy
it that make it more efficient at what,
what that red blood cell does
and then they'll shoot it in you.
It'll be a red blood cell Nano Bot
and that'll that oxygenate your blood.
And it's going to literally move on
from there until we're like Wolverine,
till we have admin Menttium
skeletons like that's not,
that's not outside the
realm of possibility. We're
meshing with machines do not,
they're probably not going to do
it the way it's in that movie,
but if you think about Wolverine,
the comic book,
the whole idea was that
he had these metal bones,
this incredible metal structure,
and then on top of that he had skin and
a a body that would heal itself like
instantly. If you caught him, it would
just seal up and you look at it like, oh,
that'd be cool. That's calming.
That's 100% it's on the horizon.
If we keep innovating, that is going
to happen. If you can hold your breath,
the bottom of the ocean to four
fucking hours on a single breath,
you're going to be,
they're going to be able to figure
out a way to make your skin heal.
Not in a week, not in
a year, not six months,
but in six seconds. Grow skin.
They're going to, they're
going to be able to do it.
Why don't we going to
be able to gene dope?
Like what is this like
the miles and it's common.
It's common myostatin inhibitors.
That's what the accidentally have
when they in breed, those dogs,
those whippets and those
cow and those cows.
But they've also started doing
it intentionally to mice.
They had created the mice live longer.
They live long or lose muscle.
Dave giant muscles, they
look like hulk mice. CVO,
pull up a picture of the
hulk mice, Hulk mice, uh,
myostatin inhibitors or so. So when do
I get that? Cause I want to be built.
I want to get into USC.
No, if you, you, you,
your comedy would be fucking horrible.
You know,
you always want to be vulnerable up
there. Your style, your whole true.
I have to rewrite your whole life.
I know.
I talk about how I'm built for
how I'm built for dance. Not,
not for war can bit that you did.
I really enjoyed seeing you. Uh,
when Brian and I,
we work together,
sometimes we're going to be working
together in Toronto September 19th. Um,
but we, we worked together recently
just just by freak accident.
I was in town filming my TV show while
he was working at the Improv in DC.
So I came by and got a chance to watch
your said, oh my God, it was so fun.
The fucking, the shit of a running through
wheat and we were, me and Todd were,
we were crying,
laughing.
There's nothing,
it's still one of my most satisfying
experiences and as far back as I can
remember,
is listening to you hackle at my jokes
when I was doing standard wash and one of
my best friends in the world. There's
nothing more satisfying. I swear to God.
I'm not just saying this like,
I was thinking about that,
to be able to make somebody like you,
not only a great comic,
but such a close friend.
I was killing you and I could see you
cackling and just loving the stuff that I
wrote. You know, it's like I
did this and my, one of my best,
like on my brother's out there laughing
his ass off. That's a beautiful feeling,
man. I've never, I haven't had a
feeling like that in a long time.
Loved that as well.
That's one of the things I love most
about working with guys like Joey
[inaudible] and Ari and red band and you
know, Dunkin is that we love each other.
So like if I see the,
you're just fucking howling back there.
Here Diaz is even better
when Diaz is laughing,
when I hear him,
I hear him.
I had a new bit it last week in Vegas.
We were working together,
we did the joint in Vegas and I heard,
I could hear Joey out of 2000 people,
thousand people,
your DHEAS when I was doing this
new bit, he was, yeah man, it's,
it's what we, it's what we were talking
about before about needing support,
you know, uh, about like people when they
get through things they need support.
And it's also why you need
to learn how to lose things.
You also need to be around
other folks that are,
that are fun and warm and
friendly. And that's, that's big.
And people that you respect
and you look at them and they,
they make you want to like
get your shit together.
They make you want to get
things done and if you can,
if you can accumulate as many of
those people as you can in your life,
the more you can do that in,
the more you can be.
When those people and more you can
accumulate those people, the more happy,
more enjoyable this thing's
going to be for you.
Yeah. I, you know, um, David plans
to in a new special pretty soon.
What is he going to do? Stand
still for a year? Yeah. No,
he's doing job for one year.
Wait till you see I helped him edit his,
this is his tray is a
steel standing still.
Wait till you see what he's doing now.
Six months in.
Can You keep it up ladies and
gentlemen of Standing Still? No, no.
He's doing magic for the likes of
Bill Gates and Stephen Hawking. Oh,
I tell you what,
you could do a card trick or for the,
Stephen is pretty fucking easy. You know
what? He move his, you know what he said?
I know. All I know is the dude.
He can't see your fucking sleeves.
He sees like a slit, like a
gun, like iron man's eyeballs.
That's what he sees. Forward way to
leave. See why he came to my house.
He did my podcast. Okay. He comes. No,
a David Blaine and he comes to my house
and I have a couple of my friends.
They're all right. Brandon shoved up
David a couple of days. They're like,
whatever. I stayed with Blaine, he
starts doing magic for them. Okay,
that's a Douche move.
That's like you come into someone's
house and start doing your act.
Cause I asked the magazine and I
asked him to, it's even worse now.
How about someone coming to your
house and you ask him to do jokes?
That's even worse. He did it.
Listen until you see him do,
until you see him hold that thought.
Okay,
well next time he's in like we'll hang
out and I just want you to notice this
conversation. Minds will be blown.
You're going to go, he's magic.
He's really magic.
That's what you're gonna say.
Just you suggesting that that
could ever happen is exhausting.
And I am and I'm standing by it.
And,
and when you're going to do a podcast
and go, Brian was right. Brian is right.
So exhausted. He's a freak. He's magic.
He does magic. Does he do magic? Oh,
but the point I was making is that he
said he was, I was just announced last,
but he was saying the most important
thing is just surrounding yourself with
people that support
him. I mean, I haven't,
but everybody I know is successful
always says that sits in one extent.
You've got to have people around you
that help you go through this shit.
I don't care how successful you are.
You always go periods where you're lonely.
Word socks,
where
you don't think you self doubt.
You gotta have your fucking friends.
How many times have I called you? What?
When you and I have real talks where,
where you know, you, you gotta say
it has all those on file. Now I know.
How about that? Oh, had that.
Hey Snowden, stay where you are.
Did you see that crazy video,
that MSNBC video where this
woman who is an anchor,
she's an anchorperson,
starts like mocking Snowden and
telling him to turn himself in.
Know it's this,
it's psychologically,
it's one of the weirdest
things you could ever watch.
It's like you try to look at it and go,
I have not sure what the motivation is.
I have never met a single person that
doesn't think that what he exposed is
important for people to know.
Not One person people have disagreed
with why he did it or how he did it or,
or what was done like to compromise
American security if anything,
but no one and no one thinks that that
wasn't important for people to find out
about it.
So it's a very subtle and nuanced case
and it's very complicated and it's also
very significant historically because
we know that things are out of control.
Now,
this is not a doubt in the world when
they're looking at every God damn thing
that you're doing, everything that
everybody do. You Walk your photograph to?
I was in London recently, not
just that graph, 255 times.
The fact that everyone's emails
are being looked at everyone.
And then this Snowden guy who was just
working there could intercept anyone's
email.
That means other people that are working
for the CIA or the NSA rather could
just intercept your emails so you could,
you know,
tell people that you're going to go eat
some shit and you know, they go, oh,
Brian cows eating shit. They know
what you're doing. A regular person,
not a Cyborg, not a monk, not
a person without a motion,
not a person without weirdness
or jealousy or, or uh,
hatred or someone to any one person can
just decide to look at your shit that
works. It's called the tyranny on it. It's
called tyranny. It isn't necessarily a,
nobody's making enough of a fuss about it,
in my opinion.
That's not the American way. So look at
this woman's reaction. We're going to,
I'm going to play this shit because
this is going to freak you out.
I know.
Really important relationships and we're
talking about how you praise countries
like Russia and Venezuela or standing
against human rights violations and with
using the compromise their
principles. Seriously. Ed,
why do you even come up with
that? What are you thinking? No,
I understand you don't want to come a bag.
I mean to do so would mean
giving up your freedom.
Definitely before trial and my thing
for several months, a years thereafter,
I get it.
It's,
it's an prisons in the u s that
commit actual human rights violations.
We just talked about it more than
more than 80,000 prisoners are held in
solitary confinement,
some for years,
some indefinitely despite the fact that
solitary is cruel and psychological
damage damaging. I know those aren't
the human rights violations though,
ed,
that you were complaining about,
but what you might have
nothing to worry about anyway.
Because unlike most of the
people in solitary confinement,
including including private
Bradley Manning on trial,
giving data to Wiki links you've
cultivated for yourself, uh,
a level of celebrity.
And that celebrity itself may just act
as the protection kind of another kind of
cloak.
If you ever find yourself in a US prison,
you have made quite a
spectacle of yourself and the
Obama administration will be
very careful about how it treats you.
Unlike how states treat all those other
prisoners. It's a come on. Oh Med.
Then you know we could
talk about something else.
Sincerely Melissa.
Hmm. That's a strange video. First of
all, it's strange that he got greenlit.
Yeah there's some producer said, I like
it. Let's do it. Let it let it rip.
We love your copy.
You're really good at reading.
That's like once she's one of the worst
persons they had reading something on
television than I've ever seen.
Right.
So first of all you can see that she's
got some sort of a speech impediment.
Yeah. But she's struggled
with since she was young,
which probably led her to have this
very strong desire for acceptance,
which probably led her to think that it
would be a good thing to like support
the government against
Snowden in that video.
I mean I guess that's what she was saying.
I mean it was,
it was a really hard to figure out
what she was saying cause all she was
admitting that the government puts people
in solitary confinement. She was also,
you know like saying like
where do you get this stuff?
Like talking about that Venezuela and
Russia stands up for human rights.
Good things about podcasting
for my learning lesson has
been like is how careful
you have to be about saying things
you think you know the answer to.
Isn't that amazing
that you didn't do that much
and you still are careful
but it's part of talking shit and here's
the fun entertaining shit. Doggies.
Occasionally you get your facts a
little bit fucked up. All right.
We're not scientists here
fight. I'm trying. My best of me
that woman was doing was like,
was really like ill advised.
It was ill advised arrogant.
It's,
it's a very complicated issue and
the way she's approaching it since,
so we can talk about other things.
Sincerely Melissa, Melissa, Melissa,
this thing that you don't want to
talk about might be one of the most
significant events in human history.
You know why?
Because we realize that there's
no such thing as privacy.
I don't know if that's
sunk in with everybody yet,
but it really is very close.
I mean,
right now it's in the government's hands
and that will eventually trickle down
to the people.
I think it's a huge problem. I
think. I think the fact that I never,
that I'm always being watched by a video
camera somewhere is video cameras are
one thing. But Monitoring,
monitoring my emails,
you guys don't tell me that you're doing
that. You don't need a, you don't need a,
um, a warrant. That's insane.
That's not, that's not it, right?
It doesn't, it doesn't make any sense.
And by the way, everybody, sorry to say,
by the way again, but remember
that every, every dictatorship,
every single oppressive government in
history has always used national security,
uh, as an excuse to take your freedoms
away. That's always the excuse, isn't it?
Look at history.
It's always,
it's a dangerous world and we're
here to protect you. Nah, no thanks.
Don't trust you. What's a classic thing
to do to actually pump up an enemy,
to get them to become a threat?
So that you can go and attack them.
That's your reason to keep the war
machine going. That's right. Yeah. It's,
and you know what,
man?
That's what happens when you get people
that make money off of war and that's
what it's supposed to be. A bunch of laws
in place to keep that from happening.
You know?
That's why Eisenhower gone on television
and warned about the dangers of the
military industrial complex
when he was leaving office.
All of that exists because it's,
it's just like with corporations
do to other countries. You know,
if you're a good person,
you wouldn't go to Venezuela and steal
their oil and pollute the rivers.
You wouldn't do it.
Okay.
You wouldn't do it because you would see
the people cry and see people starve to
death and see the fish die and you'd
go, wow, what I'm doing is fucked up.
But if you're some evil chemical company
and the way to make money is to do
that, and you have stockholders and you
have all these people that are putting
pressure on you,
that doesn't answer the equation so much.
One of those leather chairs
that has those, those rivets,
those brass rivets like dug deep into
it like an a million different places.
Those puffy leather chairs where they
always have like some brandy on a shelf,
you know with some glasses and a tub
of ice that they clink clink as they're
pouring a drink. Talk, listen, we have a
bottom line and I'm not going to Ecuador.
You going to Ecuador, so fuck the river.
Fuck that river. Let's get that money.
And they just somehow or another,
even if it's not the decision that I
made in that sort of a fashion of an x
amount of people,
whether it's 4,000 or 400 how many people
were in that corporation decided to
act as an evil unit and decide to do some
fucked up shit to make that money nor
an inconvenient truth. Sure. And then
if they can do that, they can also,
they'll seem sort of those same
principles of action apply.
That's how war happens in the first place.
You can get a giant army of people to
behave like psychos as long as the people
around them are also behaving
like psychos. That's,
it just becomes your new reality.
People go to war that that's,
if you look at how people
are motivated to go to war,
a lot of times they are motivated
around symbols, around slogans,
around different kinds of propaganda.
That's always been the case.
That's been the case since the,
you know, the Trojan war. Uh,
and that that's it's, it's
a characteristics of human
beings that you have to,
if you're looking at human
beings as a set of ingredients,
what does this thing like? Okay. Say if
you have a car, you have a, you know,
you have a Mercedes Benz.
It's a 1996.
How many horsepower does it have? What's
a capable of doing? You know, how,
how quickly can stop from zero to 60.
What are the possibilities of this,
this unit? Well, human beings are
just like a car in that sense.
Like we have a lot of possibilities
as far as documented behavior that's
completely outside the norm. It's not
giant spectrum from killing babies.
To helping old people across the
street and planting flowers everywhere.
Whole rape w well there's just
so much going on inside the,
the possibility drawer.
If you open up the possibility
drawer of human beings like, Ooh,
you better sit down cause this is
mother fuckers came above a la shit.
Incredible cruelty. Incredible kindness.
You know? So everything in between. Yeah.
So when you lump them all together
without personal accountability,
you're going to open up the
potential for all this craziness,
all the worst aspects of human beings
when they don't have a direct action
reaction input.
That's when the people that are,
when there's no accountability and
hide behind a huge institution.
It is. And it's almost not
even about hiding behind it.
It's almost not even about
not having any accountability.
It's a matter of not feeling it.
Whatever you're doing,
you're not feeling this.
One is the reasons why people can
go fuck you to someone in their car.
You can drive in the fuck you,
but it was on the street and
that guy was that close to you.
You wouldn't say fuck you to him.
I wouldn't stick your finger at him.
You would have to be crazy
because you've got to read,
you've got to respond to that person
in front of your, you're interacting.
There's that. Malcolm Gladwell did that
amazing study about how murder rate,
the murder rate went
up when they built it.
They had to ghettos and after they
built those huge, huge projects,
all of a sudden you didn't leave the next,
the guy you lived in and the guy lived
in a unit above you and there was
anonymity created so you could still
shoot somebody for their shoes cause you
didn't know them. You didn't know
somebody who was connected to them.
You didn't know that the
fabric that they came from,
it used to be windows stack
in the car in the Bronx. When,
when all of those communities came up,
they came up around a barter system
around an economic system that kind of
happened organically when they put the
cross Bronx expressway in there and they
tore everything down and they
said, you know, we're going to do,
we're going to plan the Bronx on a board,
and they plan on a board
and they had these big ha,
they created these big projects. Let's
just put them all in these big buildings.
All of a sudden the murder
rate went up and one of the,
one of the theories is the fact that you,
and suddenly now,
because even if you were in a ghetto,
you knew that kid's grandmother,
you knew that kid's brother. You didn't,
there was always, everybody was connected,
right? You all knew each other. The
minute you put people in those buildings,
now they're living in boxes and
he's living on a fifth floor.
You live in on the first floor or whatever
and you don't have an interaction.
There was no, the economic fabric
of that community was destroyed. So,
so it became much easier to shoot somebody
you didn't know somebody new in your,
in your close proximity and don't
have a relationship with them.
And they're right on top of exactly,
which is very unnatural for humans.
And this is where I always say that,
you know,
if you think you can walk around and
being, be being ignorant in today's world,
you're wrong about that.
Political commitment is important.
And knowing why you believe something.
And the,
this is a classic example
in my opinion of, of uh,
a threat that is very insidious.
It's not obvious right now.
It may not be obvious, but that's why
the Snowden case is very important.
It's important to, to at least
you don't have to have an opinion.
Just familiarize yourself, familiarize
yourself with how these things happen.
History
repeats itself. No, that your freedom
can be taken away from you in 2013.
April 10. And she is being taken
away in this country. Well, you know,
and there was a painless, no one's
doing anything. My freedom just relax.
Stop getting crazy right.
Instead of looking at it in any way
that connects you to it personally.
Whether you're defending it or whether
you're, you know, you're, you're,
you're violently opposed to it.
Look at it as a trend,
as a human trend.
And then it becomes fascinating because
if you take yourself outside of it and
you, you go, instead of going, we
have to stop this corrupt government.
Just look at it like step back and
look, look, look at what's happening.
Like what is this? What
is this? What is this?
This is a strange little thing happened
and here's a convergence. But why,
why am I know Cam a soft
crimes? I know cameras do a
lot of good things. Good, but,
but you have to add the plan. We keep
bringing up the camera, but they're,
they're everywhere. I'm not I, and by the
way, I feel safer sometimes cause yeah,
I'm sure it has.
It has a positive effect.
But to what degree are we talking about
what, what, what is the tradeoff and,
and who is,
who is saying enough is enough?
Where is the check and balance? That's
what I want. It doesn't exist. Okay,
well that's, that's a problem.
Not only does it not exist,
it can't exist if you'd follow
the pattern of human behavior.
It's like when rich people got
cell phones, do you remember that?
It was a long ass time ago,
1980s and nineties.
The like only rich people have phones
and you would occasionally seen a phone
and it was like a cool thing. I
remember uh, this comic looked into, um,
you know Jackie Flynn. Yeah. Funny
Guy. I Love Jack. Jackie, uh, is,
he's always had like a couple bucks is
families successful business and he was
always a part of that and
he had a real nice car.
He had a Toyota supra and another
comic looked in the window and he said,
oh I love the way that phone looks.
Cause he had a phone in his car.
I was like 1989 or something like that.
Nobody had,
Jackie plays a mean game
of golf to, at her. Yeah.
He's got this phone in his car
and it was like, Whoa, whoa.
Which people can have
phones in their cars.
Not Everybody has a fucking phone in
their pocket that they carry around with
them everywhere.
Eventually it got so far,
I was in Brazil and I saw these people
in this very poor neighborhood and they
all had phones. They're on their
phones or talking on phones.
It's like it's become so worldwide and
in world spread and right now information
is freely accessible only to the people
in the highest points of government.
Right now it's only the people in the NSA,
the people that have made these shitty
inside deals with Internet providers and
have gotten access to phone calls and
records and text messages and shit. They,
it's only them,
but that's just a trend.
It's going to start with them and then
the technology is slowly but surely going
to be available to everybody.
That might be a good thing, right?
It might be a good thing,
but it's going to be a different
thing and here's a problem. Money,
because money right now
is just ones and Zeros.
Money right now is just confidence.
It's just information.
It doesn't exist anymore. There's no like,
I mean you can have $1 million. Exactly.
It's not a goal. It's not like you have a
stack of gold, like you have $1 million.
So if you go to that bank, those
million notes, you can turn them in,
they'll give you a million, you
know, x amount of pounds of gold,
that equals $1 million and it doesn't
exist anymore. So if it doesn't exist,
what is it made out of? What's made
out of ones and Zeros? It's all it is.
It's made it a confidence in ones and
Zeros and the rest of it is just woven
into this complicated system that's
called our financial structure.
But if you looked at that
objectively, you go, well, yeah,
we have a very complicated system.
There's no need to worry.
Like you stop and you go,
what are you talking about?
You have a bunch of
computers and ones and Zeros.
You don't have a real money that
you don't have a real substance.
So my point is that I have a theory that
as information becomes more and more
freely distributed, it's going
to, it's going to happen.
It's going to get to a point
where there's no boundaries.
There's no boundaries between thoughts.
Everyone's going to be able
to read each other's minds.
You're all gonna be able to communicate
through Wifi and you're all going to
know everything that everybody else knows.
You're not just going to
know what you tell me.
I'm going to know what's
going on in your mind.
I'm going to know what you can remember
the central neural net and we're going
to be able to create artificial
recording of memories.
It's far more accurate than the shitty
memories we carry around in our brain and
when that happens,
you're going to have access to mind and
I'm going to have access to yours and
it's going to be a requirement eventually
that everybody has some sort of a
neuro recorder cause people are
gonna want to know what you're doing.
They're go want to have full
access to your thoughts and idea.
We're going to be able to
solve all the crimes instantly.
That's going to be the answer to it.
They're going to say there's
going to be 100% accountability.
No one will ever get away with a crime
again because we're all going to know
exactly what everybody does when they
do it. So we're all going to sign up.
What's that say about privacy?
There's going to be none,
but the point by point is
money's going to go that way too.
There's going to be no money anymore.
It's gonna,
it's gonna reach the point where
it's just resources and it's just,
there has to be some sort of a fair
system as far as the distribution of
resources.
But the idea that you're going to keep
them in a bank and get them out with a
card, good fucking lie.
It's ones and Zeros, man.
It doesn't mean it's not
gonna mean anything when
everyone can get access to it.
They've already figured out a way.
Um,
they're on the preliminary stages
where they can, they can map, they can,
I guess you,
they show you an image and then they
look at your brain activity when you see
that image. And then when you, they
show you the image again, they,
the brain activity in it shows
up on the same kind of pattern.
So you recognize something
and they can tell.
So what the idea is that if
you rob the bank or you are in,
you are a criminal and you
were in a certain place and
they give you uh, the, and,
and they, they show you that
place and they scan your brain.
When they tell,
when they tell you about the place and
your brain registers a certain thing,
they can show you a picture of it.
If your brain registers that image again,
the same kind of brain activity,
they can tell whether you've
actually seen it before.
It was this weird kind of idea, you
know, so we're getting closer and closer.
But when you say a Zeros and ones,
you're talking about money
no longer being real. Uh,
this guy named James Rickards who wrote
a book called currency wars did my
podcast,
the Pentagon hired him
to stage a currency war.
Uh,
so,
so simulate what's something someone like
China could do to our currency system
and because it's all computerized and
it's all sort of ones and Zeros, he,
he basically was hired by the Pentagon
to come up with a scenario whereby the
Chinese could set up say 10 fake
hedge fund companies that ended up,
you know,
doing something to buying all this
stock or buying just up a bunch of and
getting the market to crash.
It'd be a very difficult thing to do.
But that was his job.
It was pretty fascinating,
would be with the idea where where
there is no real money you can really
manipulate with through computers,
sort of an entire segment of the
economy and recap it theoretically,
you know,
and that's something the Pentagon hires
people that try to do in stimulate.
But it was really, really an interesting
kind of concept. Well if you,
if your money is based on a computer,
I mean it's based on calculations.
You can protect it,
you can put up firewalls and you can do,
but essentially it's just as vulnerable
as a computer is. And that's what,
you know,
one of the things about the financial
system that I've found to be terrifying
when I found out that stocks can be traded
by bots and that they could recognize
trends and trade like second to second,
like do these split second analysis of
trends and constantly keep earning money
that way by exploiting the system and
understanding which way things are moving
and buying and selling.
So you just chipping away at
the block every couple seconds,
making a little bit here
and a little bit there,
but taking essentially very little risks.
And by doing that they can figure out a
way to just extract money through a Bot
and that this is legal and that this
is it. This is how people use the stop.
You take a spread, you mean?
Or they figure out which
way things are going. Right.
And the, by the way, the
Bot, by the way, by the way,
the bots can do calculations and an
input trades faster than a person can.
Yeah. And they're, you know,
they're connected to whatever the fuck
our financial system is. I mean, I,
when I see the Dow and I see those fucking
numbers scrolling through the bottom,
to me that looks like a close encounters
of the third kind inside of the
spaceship. Like if they had
the inside of the patient,
when they show the alien language
to me, Bro, it's Greek to me. It's,
but it's Greek to everyone. Even if they
understand it, it's still in sanity. It's,
it's, I shouldn't say Greek,
but yeah. In a way, look,
grace is fucking bankrupt right now.
You know,
how crazy is it that at one point in time,
the greatest culture on the planet earth,
the most knowledgeable and that full field
was scholars creating beautiful works
of architecture and stuff that people
still read today still inspired by today.
You know, some of the great
Greek masters and then today,
what is going on over there now?
Nothing.
The fucking whole thing's falling apart
is Detroit, is Detroit, the country,
there's no money there.
It's a fucking wreck.
The whole thing is going bankrupt is
80% unemployment rate or something crazy
like that. It's just bananas. The
whole thing's a fucking disaster. Yeah,
that's right. Like these civilizations
can hit these insane heights,
but then come Trump crumbling down
Greece is a good example of what
we're talking about. You know,
you're talking about trends. There's
also something called a tipping point.
Shit happens. Start. Things start
happening. If you don't pay attention,
things will cascade in a moment.
So nobody didn't grease
thought that their,
their system was going to
collapse until it was too late.
And I say that's the same thing
that can happen with your freedoms.
I think that's the same thing if
you're not careful, if you don't know,
if you don't, if you're not paying
attention to who the the real enemy is,
or at least you don't make enough noise
or you're not paying attention to what's
going on. That's, that's the
kind of stuff that can happen.
Well, it's also individuals, again,
looking out for themselves, trying to,
trying to extract money. It's individuals
exploring a system of shitty system.
Sure. Individuals exploring
it. I mean the whole,
the housing market in this country for
the people that don't understand it,
which is by the way everybody, by the
way, by the way, nobody understands it.
That's how it happened.
And you know,
you can sort of be armchair
quarterback and you know,
you could sit back Monday morning and
sort of second guess the decisions that
were made. But the reality is it's sort
of exposed that the whole thing is,
is horse shit.
And the reason why it was horse shit
was because the way it was set up,
even though it didn't last,
was a bunch of people were able to
extract insane amounts of money.
That made no sense even though it
didn't make any sense. Fascinating.
Well you should, you, you did you sell
the house, you sold the house. Right?
Did you make a shit load of money
on it? That makes no sense. Yeah.
I sold the house in the early
two thousands and I made,
I doubled the price of my house
in like a couple of years.
That's ridiculous.
There's no way that should have happened.
I didn't do anything to that house.
I mean I fixed a few things but I didn't
like completely redo it or anything
like that.
And yet the housing prices went up so
high that I could get 100% more than what
I paid.
There's a book called the big short by
Michael Lewis and he basically traces how
this all happened.
And there was really two people
according to him in this book and if I'm
remembering might've been one,
there are really two people,
one of whom Ha was has aspergers
syndrome, he was in San Jose, California,
had a lazy eye and was a true
Asberger's syndrome. And,
and basically six years before this
was looking at these mortgage backed
securities,
these tronches and,
and actually breaking them down cause he
was obsessed with numbers and actually
really knew how they worked,
how derivatives and everything worked.
And he was going,
oh wait a minute,
these houses and these algorithms aren't
reflecting real value and this isn't
making sense yet.
They're sponging these mortgage
backed securities and selling them.
And I don't think people that can
be able to pay their mortgages,
this isn't making sense.
And he was saying that six,
seven years before that
and figured it out.
And then there was another
guy who is this dude who just,
who was a broker who did this,
who I think hooked up with this guy and
started looking at it and he was like,
ew, this doesn't make any sense. This
whole system is going to collapse.
They were literally like trying to build
Noah's Ark and it's a great book called
the big short and he,
and he really does a great job of actually
showing the key players who really
saw this thing coming and were jumping
up and down and they were ridiculed for
it. Yes, I did. I saw it. If you like
inside job, read the big short cause.
It's amazing. If you don't
like to read, watch inside job,
you're not in because it's amazing
and the Guy Confronts people,
he confronts all these.
It turns out not only was,
I mean inside job was really an apt name
for it because not only was it a crazy
fucked up system that people
were exploiting the people
that were passing their
judgment and saying,
what is acceptable?
What's not acceptable would eventually
get hired by these big banking companies.
So what they would do is they would be
professors at Harvard and they would be
economics professors and
they would analyze all these
trends and they would like,
well, our recommendation is that this is
good and this is as good as that. And,
and we'll,
all they were doing was giving people
the green light to extract money and then
they would go work for those people
and get these insane fucking jobs.
So the SEC,
incredible if the FCC,
and so they looked at the trend of
people like going from, you know,
like from Harvard to the sec and the sec
to some insane job where they would get
fucking kazillions dogs here. And they'd
go, oh, oh, they just, everyone's corrupt.
The whole thing is corrupt.
It's a coop.
And when this guy's like confronting
these people and that movie inside job and
they're like freaking out and reacting
to him, it's pretty, it's pretty amazing.
It's pretty amazing.
Great. Great document.
And it will make you want
to throw a hammer through
fucking TV and we'll get you
back question.
It raises though is is that
is the incentive structure
that was set up to blame
and how do you avoid,
because smart people are going to take
advantage of a system that's broken.
So how then do you see a you,
we all know that you're never
going to control human behavior.
I mean it's going to be impossible.
And when people see an opening,
they're going to take it some people.
So the idea then is how do you create a
system that doesn't reward that kind of
behavior that seems to shout
even possible. One of the,
one of the ways that smart
people will talk about is to say,
you still have this guy, James
Rickards, who was, um, on my show,
said the problem with too big to fail,
the eight biggest banks in the
country are, are bigger than ever.
And what that means is that the u
s government can't let them fail.
They can behave very irresponsibly.
I'm not saying they are right now,
but they can if they wanted to behave
very irresponsibly and they, and if they,
if they screw up again,
we have to bail him out because they
are the central nervous system of our
financial structure.
But the crazy thing is that it was all
warned about a long ass ago. The idea
of a bank being too big to
fail is it's a refuted premise.
Nothing's happened about, doesn't work,
nothing's happened about it. No nothing,
nothing has happened.
Not In worse in some way.
And what was my favorite part about it
was when they were talking about the
bonuses and that Obama was going to limit
them to the $500,000 because guys were
still getting bonuses like millions and
millions of dollars and they're like,
well they have to pay
them because they don't.
These guys are going to go
work for someone else. And
I remember thinking like,
where are they going to work? They're
going to work for who? How much money?
How could you possibly get a
bonus when your bank is folding?
Like what is the bonus food?
The answer to that. If you listen,
a lot of people as they go,
guess what banks do it. They don't live
in a capitalist society. First of all,
they call Obama a socialist.
They're the,
they're the biggest socialist and
the planet. They have socialized,
there are losses and privatized their
gains. You lose. Don't worry, the bank,
the governor bail you out big to fail.
Buddy went out there with that.
You guys talk about being capitalist.
You guys went out there with you.
Well we failed. Somebody bails
out but you, you privatized,
you make all the money.
You live in a private economy.
You your talk about the, the,
the market system and the
free market enterprise
bitching about this stop for a
second and what would you do?
What would I do? What would
you do? I'm getting him.
You're going to give me the king of
the world. I'm going to allow you,
you unlimited.
First thing I would say, first thing I
would do is this campaign finance reform.
What does that mean? Take money
out of politics. Why in the world?
Why in the world and, and, and again,
I'm sorry to bring up another
book but don't go to a book,
go to the Ted Lecture and, and listen
to, um, uh, it's called, uh, uh,
republic lost by Lawrence Lessig and,
and basically here's how it goes.
If you're a politician in this country,
you are beholden to fundraisers.
You spend all your time,
40% of your time calling people you
don't know for money cause you're not
getting elected otherwise.
How do you solve that problem?
Take money out of politics.
There are ways to do it. I,
I'm not gonna sit here and tell you
how there are ways to do it where money
doesn't play a big as big enough role
because now we are in an economy of
influence.
You cannot do business as a private
corporation without having a pipeline to
Washington.
You can't,
it takes two hours to get into
Washington cause it 13,000 lobbyists are
descending on that, on that capital
every fucking day. Okay, so,
so as long as you create an economy of
influence and you have corporations that
are manipulating that massive structure,
what do you think it started there?
Do you think the solution is the
Internet? Well, that's my second thing.
The the,
there is an America that works and
that America that works is the kind of
commerce that is going on on the Internet,
Ebay and all this other stuff and,
and the government hasn't yet gotten
involved. That's still a wild frontier.
And guess what? Guess what? You and
I, regular people know how to do it.
We don't need a bunch of licenses
and government intervention people.
The Internet works. It's also works. You
can't have a bunch of things that are
going to influence all of us happening
behind closed doors. You just
can't. Of course not. You can't.
You're talking about the NSA now.
People need to know,
like if there's environmental issues
that are coming up and they're being
debated inside some closed door where
people are making deals and those, those,
those decisions that they're making
could fuck us all up. Those, they can't,
that can't happen.
No one should have that ability.
No one should have that kind of power.
She had a caveat though very quickly to
that there is something called secret
deliberation. There's nothing
wrong with it and I've finished,
let me finish with this
sentence. When, when,
like if you look at the Supreme Court,
when they did,
when they come to a decision they had,
they were trying to a room and it is a
secret sort of deliberation that media is
not there because it requires
lots of sober thought.
It requires changing your mind.
You can't have people listening
and watching the process however,
however different things it is because,
because the decision exactly.
Cause this decision finally is a public
decision that still has to be that,
that that that we contend with them.
We know about,
well not only that,
but when someone is in the Supreme Court,
the theoretically at least they have the
responsibility to adhere to the letter
of the law and anyone influencing that,
anyone outside of the supreme court
influencing that would be negative.
So if it was wide open to the
whole world to look at it,
then you've got all these people
influencing it and react to it and their
influence may affect that decision
gets made, but it's been hijacked.
Of course, it's been hijacked
so it, it did do get influenced.
When you hear the Supreme Court passed
shit that says like a corporation can act
as an individual and they can donate as
much money as they want to a campaign.
When you have those kinds of decisions
being made, you go, oh they got, yeah,
they got to you.
If there's widespread spying
on, on its citizens, if,
if a government is spying
on its citizenry secretly,
if they are collecting information
from right, ordinary citizens,
I want to know about it.
Let's have the debate publicly.
Tell me if it's really that
important to stop terrorism.
Can we have a public debate?
I want to know about what's going to
happen that Snowden and dude that's going
to be here.
He's going to stay in Russia because we
don't have an extradition treaty with
them. Well, if he's smart,
he would stay in Russia.
I don't think the dude should come back.
That's for fuck shore.
I don't think you should come back.
I never should be a debate.
I just think there should be a debate,
a real debate about what the hell
is going on with the NSA and, and,
and how we navigate this problem.
But meanwhile they're trying to
not talk about it. Like, you know,
everyone was talking about the,
the new royal baby and everyone's talking
about Andrew Wiener within his cock
out. I know Geraldo Rivera
taking his shirt off, man.
Well drones are slamming in the
hut. Look, you know it's Thoreau.
Thoreau said, I see man everywhere
striking at the, at the branches of evil,
while none are hitting the route,
you got to know where the root starts man.
So you know, know what the end, where
the real enemy is. That's very important.
Before you strike out, you got to know
and that takes, that takes some work.
You got to earn that and that.
That's why I recommend the book republic
lost or@leastgototed.com and listen to
Lawrence Lessig give,
show you why we are losing our republic.
He does a very good job about it.
People argue with it.
Sat next to a guy on a plane who was an
editor at Newsweek who said he doesn't
know what he's talking about, but I was
very convinced and it was very scary.
Well,
I think that the responsibility for
running this entire society cannot rest in
secret hands anymore and I think
the only way for society progressed,
the way the culture of human interaction
has progressed since the Internet.
The only way to cite for society
to catch up is to take away power.
They have to relinquish
power that it has to be done.
That's the only way
you're going to have a,
a culture that is advancing commensurate
with the amount of people that are
advancing.
Because otherwise you're going to have
a bunch of people that are trying to
control and steal resources and hold
on to influence and hold on to power.
And they're going to realize that
there's fucking pounding at the gates
everywhere and they're not
going to open up the gates.
They're going to try to bolt them down
more and they're trying to scare people
away from the gates.
And that's what we're seeing now.
What we're seeing now with things like
going after these whistle blowers as if
they were the most evil people
in the world. Meanwhile,
the government itself is responsible
for thousands of people dying in drone
attacks that were innocent.
That's thousands of murders and no
one is getting in trouble for these
accidental murders. Accidental
of course, but murders still.
But yet this Snowden guy
is public enemy number one,
and they're pulling down planes with
the president of Austria in them they're
diverting planes because they
thought that he was going to Austria.
They land with this fucking guy. And
they're like, let me check your plane.
And then he's like, what the
fuck are you doing? Like,
cause they thought that Snowden
was on this cat's plane.
I mean they're taking planes out of the
sky, royal planes from other countries.
It's craziness.
And why is it because this guy caught
people doing shit that is illegal,
immoral, and not wanted by any of the
people that voted folks into power.
If you had to vote today,
should the NSA be able to
look at everyone's email
and everyone's fucking cell
phone records? We all say no.
100% if you didn't say no,
you're a bit not an American.
You're a fucking cunt.
You fascist piece of shit.
You want any.
But because here's the deal about the
government, they're just people. Okay.
There is no government. There is a bunch
of people that act as the government.
But the reality of the government
is they're just people.
And if there was only two of them
people, by the way, I mean, you know,
imagine if there's only two Q government
and then you're the only population is
two people in government and you're the
population and they're telling you you
can't smoke weed. We're going to lock in
a cage. They tell you would kill them.
You would say,
okay,
well I'm living with these people and
have to kill because they're trying to,
they're trying to stop me from doing a
bunch of shit that doesn't have anything
to do with them.
The idea only becomes reasonable when
you're governing 300 million people,
then it's okay to throw them in a cage
if you catch them with a trunk full of
heroin.
But if we were on an island together and
it was just you and me and I caught you
doing heroin, I'd be like,
dude, what are you doing?
I wouldn't build a fucking
bamboo cage and you know,
dig a hole and throw you
in the bottom of it. Yeah.
The other issue is this, you, you,
if you have a government where the
people in it may be good people,
but the, but the only way to get ahead
is by acting and behaving corrupt.
That's where,
that's the insidious thing.
Let me give you an example of when
you go to Capitol Hill and you are on
politician and you're making 120
grand a year. You know what you're,
you know what? That's, you know what
you are in, you're in Grad school.
You know what the, you know what the big
Kahuna is? You know what you wanna do.
You want to work there for six,
seven,
eight years in Lawrence Lexicon does a
good job of showing this and then you
want to go work on k street for a lobbying
firm making 500 600 $700,000 a year.
That's the goal.
Government has become big business.
Government has become
a business unto itself
and it's this, just like any other
business becomes competitive.
People want to get ahead,
they want to,
and the only way to get ahead is to
make progress and want to make progress.
To move forward.
What's it doing right now?
I've got to move it for
the only way to make money.
It's not by pulling back and having
less water and less this and less that,
less control and know the way to make
money inside this system is to keep it
pushing forward. That's right. But I think
it's going to lose its power. I just,
I don't think that's
going to be a revolution.
Yeah. As you talk, I, I,
one of the things I was thinking about
as I'm optimistic in the sense that I
don't know how you control,
you can't control the truth.
The Internet is the access to information
that people have has never been better
in that sense. And, and we are
developing our own autonomy in many ways.
Look at you and I have a business that
we run primarily through the Internet.
I mean, uh, you know, developing
an audience, doing podcasts,
all these kinds of
things going on the road,
you can actually start
becoming your own entity,
your own sort of source of income,
your own everything.
And that's pretty new. I mean
so much of it is, you know,
owning your own business,
branding yourself has never
been easier in some way.
Never been easier. I would've
never been able to do it before.
And I was very fortunate enough to witness
many different aspects of the birth
of the Internet.
And one of the things that I got a chance
to witness was I was there when the
UFC existed only on the internet.
Yeah.
The U of C lost its ability to be on
cable. They got banned from cable.
So the only way people knew
about it is if you had direct TV,
which wasn't as popular
back then as it is now.
I mean we're talking about the 1990s the
early nineties and other than that like
you would,
he would hear about it on the Internet.
You would go on these like forums with
your shitty ass modem. You're 56 k modem,
like a chunk, a chunk, chunk, chunk,
chunk of as it was like slowly like move
its way down the page until he could
download the website.
And that's how I found out almost about
all the events and different things that
were going on there, like the mixed
martial arts.com it used to be,
I think it was submission fighting.com
and then it was mixed martial arts.com
there was an mma.tv and then it's mixed
martial arts.com and it became at some,
what's that noise dialing?
What is that? Okay.
Don't do that. Thanks. Yeah, the,
that sound that mean that those,
those websites from back then like
doing that was the only way people
communicated about information.
If it wasn't for that, no
one would have any idea.
There was even still on anymore.
Once you pull shit off cable,
it's like it doesn't exist
anymore. It's gone. Yeah.
But because of people like where the
fuck did you go? Whoa, what's going on?
And so they would get online and people
that these communities sort of developed
where people started
talking about things online.
So I got to see a sport mixed martial
arts literally go from almost dying to
being partially revived to taking off all,
primarily through the momentum of the
Internet. Yeah. Incredible. Yeah, it's,
this is a totally stand up comic and
being a musician or being a, you know,
I mean look at even even like TV shows
Hassett cars winning all these awards,
man, it's strictly Internet. You
know, we're getting everything from,
why wouldn't you? Well, they're bringing,
but Netflix is bringing back
arrested development. Yeah.
I know. How crazy is that?
People were like, what the fuck? Why did
the camps, that was just with our will,
our net in New York, he was doing,
he had it. He's been doing it.
They got them everybody together and
10 years later they're all doing it.
There's so many people on Netflix now.
Netflix just announced we're going to
start doing standup comedy specials.
I did my first special on Netflix,
one of my first specials. Yeah.
Thinking about it. Why not fucking
great. I still do. They want,
they all watch my first special on
Netflix. Why wouldn't they watch?
Why not just go right to
Netflix and do it. To this day,
I get tweets about my 2005
special yeah. From, from Netflix.
That was the one,
the beginning of the whole eat the
sandwich thing about a society and human
beings are sorta like mold on a sandwich
that I think we might be here to eat
the sandwich. You know, it's, it's
the, the horrifying revelation. Right.
Did you, uh, there's a,
a recent article about the Pacific
Garbage Patch, about the, uh,
the new, uh, measurements of
the Pacific garbage patch.
It's closing in on California. It's
getting, getting closer to us. It's this,
if you haven't paid attention to,
this is something we haven't talked
about in the podcast in a long time,
but Google Pacific garbage patch,
it's essentially like there's a tide,
there's a current,
the way the oceans move,
the way the currents move,
it developed this sort of area where all
the shit that's floating in the ocean
coalesced and combined into this
enormous soup of fucking rotting plastic.
Wow.
Slowly degrading plastic that
kills millions of animals a year.
It kills scoopers. I mean
it's like Texas sized. Yeah.
It's so big. It's insane. And
it's not like a solid thing.
It's like soup. Yeah. So
it's little pieces. Yeah.
And it in the sun and in the ocean,
the saltwater and the surf and everything
like that, it's slowly breaks down to,
it's like floating pellets and shit.
Yeah.
And what's a fish and everything eats
it. They eat it and they die. Fish.
Birds that eat it and they die.
It's just a millions of them and it's,
the whole thing is enormous and no one's
cleaning it and it's getting bigger.
It's constantly getting bigger
people or leave the new technology,
three d printing and stuff like that.
We're going to have less waste.
Less transport. Right. I mean, I don't
know. That's an interesting possibility.
I think the ultimate reality,
which would be the best,
is if we develop something that can eat
plastic and somehow you can control it.
Well, they have those kinds of
things, but it's, it's close. Yeah.
But it's also a look. What happens once
it gets done eating plastic. Well, hm.
I like people to write no more plastic.
Let's start eating feats.
There are bacteria that you
can, you know, that we do use,
I guess enzymes and bacteria
that actually do that now,
but whether or not it's biocompatible
and yeah, those are the questions.
Yeah. The march of science.
Well, there's been some,
some thought about doing various things
to clean up the ocean and one of the
things is,
uh,
actually introducing certain
allergies and introducing iron, uh,
taking metal and creating a
metal structures and putting
these metal structures
in the bottom of the ocean that would a
attract various types of algae and that
various types of algae,
those would, uh, re oxygenate
through you, through, you know,
their use of whatever the
fuck they need in the, uh,
in the ocean and actually clean up
some of the water. And sometimes
I feel like all these problems are put
there for a reason than anything is
surmountable. Oh, you're so cute. I
know. Any reason? No, no. Do I just,
anything is anything as solvable including
then happens, happens for a reason.
So all that stuff is all annoying. It's
annoying, but then it's not right. Well,
I'm with you. I believe what
you're saying. I believe, I
believe it's a law. I mean,
anything, any challenge. Human
beings do incredible things, man.
He's going to be things come up with,
do you ever hear the story about more
the guy who created Morse code like that
was the most revolutionary as the turning
point in history? What more? More,
because if you think about it,
it Alexander the Great
in 19 who's 1820 when it was invented,
I think I hit the when the
first time they actually,
I think it was 1819 when the first time
they actually had a 10 mile stretch of
of wire and the guy was able to
send a message and before that,
think about this. Before
that the, the guy,
the guy before an 18 whatever,
1815 he had to send a
message the same exact way.
Alexander the Great did
either on horseback, either
on foot or either by boat.
Okay. And when Morse code came up and
Morris was a guy who was a really,
really successful painter. Okay. And He'd
had nothing to do with electronic Madec.
Magnetic fields are, I think was a
really successful painter. His wife,
he gets what we get to letter
that his wife is very sick.
He loved his in Connecticut. By the
time he gets there, she's not only dead,
she's been buried.
And he said,
this gotta be a way I can get information
faster because it killed them.
It was this tragedy. Seven
years later, he's on a boat.
He meets this electromagnetic engineer.
He starts talking to him.
He gets fascinated with the idea that
maybe I can come up with a way to use
electromagnetic fields to send a message.
About 10 years after that,
he invented something called Morse code,
this painter, because he was so broke,
heartbroken over his wife,
and, and, and by the end,
the world has never been the same.
That was a bigger communication leap
actually than the Internet because it was
the first time we were able to send
instantaneous messages. Uh, and,
and I think five years
later we finally had a,
a wire from New York to New Orleans,
which was so much faster and you
could get instantaneous communication.
The world was never the same.
And of course we built on that,
but there's the history so full of
individuals that we're trying to solve a
problem that seemed insurmountable and
oftentimes it was because they basically,
um, like Alexander Fleming
had a cold. He, he,
his snot fell into,
he had all these petri dishes working
on different spores and stuff,
and he decided to clean stuff out himself.
He never used to clean his own petri
dishes. He had a cold, is snot,
fell into one of the moldy dishes and
he realized that the bacteria under the
microscope, the mold that killed all
the bacteria and he went, wait a minute.
That's how we invented a little
something called penicillin,
which then became antibiotics, which is
why people are alive. It's crazy. So many,
so many of these things either happen
through accident with individuals or
people were trying to solve a problem.
Yeah.
That's one of the things about
life is that you need struggle.
It seems like you shouldn't have
it, but you need it. Oh Man.
One of the worst things that can happen
is when people don't struggle anymore
and then they start to suck and
they used to be awesome. You know,
you see it with musicians time and time
again. You see it with certain Comedians,
you see it with certain writers,
see it with certain actors,
they they lose whatever the fuck it was
that they had when they were struggling.
When they're struggling and they had a
show up and they, you know, they just,
sometimes it's good to,
to be criticized.
Sometimes it's good to fail and cause
that fail can be like a turbocharger that
kicks you into the, the
next, the next base.
A wolf at the door is usually
luxury at some of struggle.
Biggest leaps in my comedy career
have come after bombing. Me Too.
My biggest leaps,
one of my biggest ones ever in
New York came after bombing.
One of my biggest ones in
Boston came after bombing.
I've had him in La that came
after bombing. One of my,
one of the reasons why I just,
I dove back into comedy.
I bombed one night at the comedy store
when I was doing news radio and a bunch
of the writers came to watch me and I
ate Dick [inaudible] Dick at 1:00 AM.
That's terrible. He's the
main room at 1:00 AM you've
been there. That's the spot.
So I used
to get back then,
you know I was a nobody,
so I just get these spots after everybody
had ripped that place sideways and
there's 20 people left and then I
went onto this dead crowd, my shitty,
who don't speak English, just stirring
their drinks. I've been up in there.
It was death and then I realized,
Oh my God, I'm coasting.
Like I realize like I went up there,
I thought I could do the same jokes I've
been doing for years with no passion
and no energy,
no excitement to them,
and I felt it while other people took
it in because the room wasn't giving me
nothing. I had, I had to bring it myself
and you can bring it if you're good,
you can't bring it if
you actually have it.
But that's when you find
out if you're faking it,
when there's 10 people in the crowd,
you know anything less than 50 people,
you can't trick those fucking
people in the laughing.
You're either funny or you're not right,
but a 200 person,
you could sometimes why we
all know and no disrespect,
but we all know there's those people that
can go on at the laugh factory at like
eight 30 on a Friday when everyone's
laughing at everything and you can watch
this bizarre mayonnaise sandwich
of an act where you're like,
what did I even just see?
But yet the pauses are in the right place
and people are laughing and the the,
the person's dressed right and
they don't stay too long. You know,
you'd do like 10 15
minutes and good enough.
You hit on enough buzz
words that people like, Oh,
you brought up some things
that people think is funny,
like Kanye West or whatever. You know,
it's enough. You did it. You were safe.
You got through it.
Yeah.
But that same person put them on the
comedy store at 1:00 AM in front of 20
people and they will get nothing.
Zero.
The death march through those shitty
dry words tumbling out of your mouth,
like dirt,
like literally dirt
coming out of your mouth. Well, you know,
they always say that. I say, why?
Why? Why was Louis Armstrong so great?
And some of those black musicians who are
doing incredible things with the horn.
And there was this historian, I
can't remember his name. He said,
well when you were black back then,
you weren't allowed to speak your mind.
You Express yourself through
your horn man. And, and they,
that he was trying to say something,
he was really trying to sense that horn.
Yeah.
So it,
it really is a question of
what your motivation is and
how important inspiration
and motivation is to keep yourself going,
man. Yeah. You have to have something,
man.
You
gotta you gotta be Anita. I
keep myself uneasy, you know,
and I do it. I don't do it cause
I'm better than other people.
I don't do it because I'm smarter.
I don't want to,
I do it because I failed and I
realize why failed. I realize what,
what made me fail and then I
don't do it that way anymore.
It's really that simple. I am
the, I'm not better than anybody.
What I am is a guy who did a lot of shit
and failed miserably a bunch of times
and then hated that feeling and it
made sure that I didn't do that again.
So the only reason why I keep myself
uncomfortable now is that of sheer terror.
That was the feeling of that
I had before when I would,
when I've bombed or when I've, when I've
have asked something or when I haven't,
I haven't pushed as hard as I
can. So driven. I'm not as driven.
I want to see what I have inside me.
I'm curious.
I'm also really driven by curiosity.
My Ego thing isn't there? No,
I don't think so actually. What's
inside? I don't think it's an ego thing.
I think for me it's like inside me,
my buddy, my buddy I was just with,
I went to visit in Europe. He's,
he's made about a billion dollars.
Went to college with them and I'm not
kidding when I say that he's got the
craziest house and I said,
what drives you man? I said,
you own the two fastest
growing banks in Europe.
You've got crazy money to staff were
flying around in your private jet. What?
What is it that drives you?
And he said, he looked at me,
he goes, he goes, look man,
I liked building things cause I'm
never sure if I can really do it.
It's just always a rush to deal to try
to build something and see if I still
have it,
see if I can still do it,
see if it's a new challenge and just
try it and it has nothing to do with the
money. That's just like he's made
more than anybody could ever spend.
Well that's when it becomes like a
weird game that your plants where it is.
Like for Bill Gates has certain time
Bill Gates had to realize that he could
never spend all that shit.
If you get,
if you really do get to keep it like I'm
not sure what happens when you have $98
billion when it goes up 50 billion
and then down when the market shifts,
like that's the weirdest thing about
those guys when you look at it like their
net worth and then like he used
to be 90 million or 90 billion,
now it's 40 billion. You're like, well,
we'll, we'll, we'll, we'll, we'll wait.
Where the fuck did that go? Right?
Like what happened? They're like,
you lost 50 blood. Wait a
minute. What do you even saying?
But at a certain point in time,
what if he stopped now how much money
would he have every year just to spend?
It would be an insane
amount of money he's done.
There's that thing about Bill Gates 10
years ago when they said if he dropped
$40,000 out of his pocket,
it wouldn't be worth him turning around
to get it because his time is worth much
more than the time it would take actually
turn around and pick up the $40,000
make it would make, it
would be financially prudent
for him to keep walking.
That hurts my brain. I
love that stuff. Nah,
now you dropped a $40,000, whatever
it was. It's something crazy.
I was looking online at houses that like,
you know,
rich people own like oh per style houses
and Oprah, Oprah's houses everywhere.
Um,
but she's got this house in Montecito a,
which is the nice area outside of Santa
Barbara, like really old, old school,
beautiful homes,
really beautiful,
beautiful neighborhood near the
ocean and her house. It's like,
how do you have enough money for,
this is one of your houses.
It doesn't even make any
sense that one person can,
you accumulate that much money and then
when you stop and look at it and go,
wait a minute, how did she do that? She's
just talking like Oprah doesn't do shit.
She's not juggling.
She hasn't played guitar and inspiring.
She doesn't play guitar. She doesn't,
she's not the fastest race car driver.
She doesn't pull vaults.
All she does is talk and like a,
we'll be right back and like she's got a
hundred fucking kazillion cause she was
a source of major inspiration
for millions of women.
It's insane to look at her house, her
house in crazy. Oh my God. It's insane.
It's incredible.
I'm Oh in when I was doing fat actress
and she was redoing Kirsty alleys,
kitchen and uh, the culture was doing,
Huh? Why was she doing that? I don't know.
Some thing that she decided to
do redo Kirsty alleys. Kitchen.
It was going to be on the program.
You know that they showed it on the Oprah.
Oh yeah. I was there while they
were renovating and I believe that,
I'm sorry Christie,
if I'm talking out of line,
but I think it costs 700 grand
just to Redo the kitchen. Dude,
that's that a hundred grand and we
do the kitchen. I'll fucking kill it.
Was it taught, I don't know, just big, Eh,
not worth 700 grand to me. But it looked,
it was all detailed with incredible
mosaic and all that stuff.
But you got to think that she's like
really big and she probably needs a lot of
food and so you need to comment a
lot of refrigerators and shit. She,
as far as like hot chicks that
God gigantic, she's numero uno.
There's never been like a super hot
chick who got gigantic and then stayed
arrogant. She's very extreme. Yeah.
Like stayed out there, stayed bold.
She's, you know, out there, you know,
would talk about losing the weight
and then lose weight, you know,
drop a hundred pounds, you know, do
a fucking weight loss commercial.
She went cold on me too and we hung out.
I loved her kids and we did that show
and then she just never called me back.
I was like, what happened after he did
the show? You stop being an enduring. She,
we were all, we were doing fat actress.
Something happened where she, you fucker,
no, no, no. But she just went cold. I
mean, I never understood it and she,
she just, she just went dead
cold on me. And, uh, you assign,
is she a psychologist at me? Yeah, she
was signed. I'm reading going clear now.
And your recommendation, right?
Yeah. Ooh. Just you wait,
I'm about 50 pages in and just start.
Oh, oh, please continue. But it's, it's,
it's absolutely fascinating.
He also wrote a great book, uh,
Lawrence Wright about the looming
tower. Which house or bad about the, uh,
the rise of Islamic fundamentalism and
culminating in nine 11. We're fascinating.
You have to read that next. You have
to. You just have to, I would love to.
Any religious fundamentalism scares
the shit out of me. Yeah. It's just,
it's a prison of Scientology is a
religious fundamentalism and that's what's
fascinating about his book.
It religious fundamentalism has
nothing to do with the truth.
It has nothing to do with some
ancient shit that God told people.
It has to do with another
possibility of the human existence.
Just like we were talking about a car
that a car has a bunch of shit he can do,
he can hit the brakes.
You could corner at one g,
you can accelerate to 60 in five seconds.
It has all these things that it can
do well. It can also fall into a cult.
That's what a person can do.
Like this.
I would all this shit that a person
could do, a person could make coffee,
a person can use the computer, a person
can have sex and make a baby. Oh,
they can also fall into a cult.
They can also be,
we were in a Utah fill in my
show last week, Duncan and I,
and we showed up at the airport and he
was one of the strangest things I've ever
made.
Anytime life.
They had these people that were
returning from missions and uh, their,
their elders, they call them elders and
charter people there with signs, right?
Screaming like they're rock stars.
I mean high pitch cheers and screaming
and with these giant signs that say,
welcome home, Elder Richardson,
welcome whole El elder white.
My parents live in park city, so I see it.
Yeah, yeah. That's where we went. We went,
well, we went to park city.
That's what we ate at park city.
And then we did our thing, uh, which
was about two hours outside of that,
which is God's country man. Just
fucking beautiful. And Park City.
I'd only been there in the winter pants.
We went skiing there once the
winter and it was beautiful.
But then we went there in the summer
and they told me that what's even better
than skiing is you take the lifts,
the lifts operate all year round.
He take the lifts and you take a
mountain bike down those hills.
That was perfect. Ski Hills. They
say it's insane cause you got to,
you got breaks now.
She didn't go fucking drink.
You driving them fucking a bike down
those hills. It's supposed to be amazing.
You don't have to drive up. You take
the fucking the lift up, done it. Oh,
you've done it with the dirt Mike
down a mountain bike. Mountain bike.
It's supposed to be amazing. It's
supposed to be even more fun than skiing,
which sounds crazy. But uh,
the, the, the area there,
it's so God damn gorgeous man.
I've been hiking so gorgeous.
My parents house and just go hiking
and it's just, it's a do it alone.
It's incredible.
It almost doesn't bother me that all
these fucking people are crazy religious
park city. There are, there are no, there
aren't a lot of Mormon. No, they're not.
It's, it's salt lake. But you got to land
in Salt Lake and that's where you say,
hey listen. Nice piece. I say they're very
nice people. They keep it very clean. Uh,
state. I got no problem with Mormons. I
never got beat up by a Mormon. I list. I,
I have some friends that were,
Mormons were friends with
them when they're Mormons
and they eventually bailed.
There's really kind of interesting to
watch them bail on being a Mormon, uh,
because uh,
they just,
they got to a certain point in
their life where they're like,
what the fuck are we doing?
Which is really interesting to see when
people hit like 40 and then they start
doing that.
But these people living in this state
and a giant percentage of them being
involved in this one call and,
but that cult seems to work
for them for the most part.
Like they get those weird,
uh, aberrations, like they
branch off like occasionally.
And have that one guy that got arrested.
What was his name?
Jeff something or another
that, that far, yeah. Whoa.
What the fuck is that guy's
name? He was Mormon Church. Um,
I believe outlawed
polygamy. Uh, like in 18,
you know, night. Very, very, like
in the 1800 [inaudible] were there,
there was a sect that split off a bunch
of guys who are perverts who were like,
oh shit. Which I sympathize with
the freeze, right? Yes, yes, yes.
And he went to jail for
a long time. Yeah. Well,
what's even more interesting is that
one of those groups that branched off
because didn't want to
give up the polygamy,
was the guy who was running for president,
Mitt Romney's family.
Rarely.
Mitt Romney is a super Mormon.
In fact,
his family lives in Mexico.
His father couldn't run for president
because his father was born in Mexico.
So Mitt Romney was born in America,
but his dad was a part of the cult that
moved to Mexico because they didn't want
to give up the pussy. So they have these,
it used to be vote for Mitt Romney.
Next act before there were cars.
It didn't matter if you were in Mexico,
it's like you're in Mexico, United
States and the 18 hundreds it was like,
they were like, well, if you want
to, you want to be an American,
you cannot have multiple wives. They're
like, oh, but I can have multiple wives.
I just crossed that river, take
care of CLL. It's off for now.
And then all of sudden you're over
there and then someone invents something
called cars. Well, the,
the whole world changes because now
people are moving back and forth and it's
really easy to do so. And
then you realize, oh shit,
there's a wall between me and the most
prosperous area and it's right over there.
And then the area around you becomes
filled with people that are involved in
something called the drug war,
and then you're fucked.
So now his family that lives in Mexico,
they're armed to the teeth healing.
They live in giant compounds,
vice vice.com. Man,
my friend Shane Smith told me about this
is the first time I heard about it and
then I there's multiple articles
confirming this not like very interesting
phenomena. Bad Ass. And it's not like
there, um, this is speculation of theory.
You know, this is real. I mean it goes on
in there. We're not just vice, many, many,
many,
many people have documented these
Mormon cults in Mexico and there's some
serious conflict with the,
the drug lords in Mexico.
They kidnapped him cause kidnapping is
a huge source of income and like Mexico
City and a lot of places as
far as like crime, kidnapping,
people's a big deal to the point where
they tell you don't drive around a bullet.
Nice car.
I know,
but bulletproof cars specifically cause
he target those because they figured you
have money. Yes, because all your, what
do you, what's in there? Some money.
What's in the hiding something.
These are jewel of a person
in there that I can sell.
And so there they were doing that whole
economy with the families like these,
these cults that live in
these giant compounds.
She's like several families that moved
to Mexico and Mitt Romney's family's a
part of that. I'd get out of
there. Yeah. You think? Yeah. Yeah.
It's one of the weirdest aspects of
society in the year 2013 is that we are
connected to one of the most
dangerous areas in the world. Juarez.
Mexico is one of the most dangerous
spots to be a human being and live in the
world.
More dangerous in fact and I rack was,
well I think that's where the Zach does
came out of and I think they've been,
I think they've been kind of, they've
been kind of brought under control.
I don't know that the, the, the,
the issue is that the economy of
Mexico and the power structure,
the entrenched power structure itself is,
relies on the drug
economy from corruption.
Just completely out of control.
Yeah. I mean the cops, by
the way, their neighbors,
the United States of the biggest consumers
of that product. So, you know, a,
as long as there is a demand, they're
going to supply it. And uh, either, uh,
but don't legalize it,
don't legalize it will just so we've
got 52,000 body bags and counting,
I think in Mexico since this
shit happened. You know,
Mexico has silently decriminalized
drugs. Well, I don't, I don't blame them.
And I'll tell you why.
They've been the ones bearing the brunt
with real tragedy in their bodies and
their children and their neighborhoods
that they're the ones who have been
dealing with this. We've been the ones
consuming it and it's got, you know,
so I again, yet again, you know,
if people want to do something,
they're going to do it. So I'm
trying to control people's behavior.
They decriminalized everything in
2009 to try to slow everything down.
It's very rarely talked about. Like
when we talked, I didn't know that.
I'm interested in hearing that,
but I heard a little of it.
When people talk about
decriminalization though,
the example they always give is Portugal
because Portugal did essentially the
same thing. They made all drugs,
legal, they decriminalized everything.
He can't sell them, but you can
possess them. If you get caught,
they give you treatment. No one goes
to jail. Well, when Portugal did that,
they're fucking rates of addiction
dropped. Their rates of crime dropped.
But let me ask you this, when, when, and
you know more about it than I do. We'd,
for all intensive purposes in
Colorado for example, is legal.
But that's the state. That's a statutory
law. It's still not a federal law.
So the Fed can come in
actually technically close
those deposit repositories
down and all that, right? Yes. Not
only that, even the medical draw,
like the idea of medical
marijuana, the, the,
the federal government does not recognize
the fact that it's even a medicine.
So the federal government,
the reason why marijuana is a schedule
one substance is not because it's the
most dangerous. Because if it
was based on proof that it was,
it would be impossible to put
marijuana in schedule one.
But they can put marijuana in schedule
one because schedule one means has no
medicinal value. That's, that's recognized
by the state, by the federal government.
So because the fact they
put it in a schedule one,
then it refutes all the medical marijuana
clinics because mine have medical
cocaine. You can have medical, if there's
applications for opiates, like pills,
those are all legal. So you can sell this
actually a cocaine directly lidocaine.
And um, how about uh, opiates? Morphine,
yeah. And you know,
oxycontin's all that stuff.
Those are pills you could buy those you,
you can ask your doctor for
vicodins and they will give them to,
if you're in pain, those
are drugs. Okay. And,
but the federal government can't stop
your doctor from prescribing those because
they're scheduled to.
So cocaine and heroin are both scheduled
to drugs because they have medical
applications, whereas they try to
pretend that marijuana doesn't,
and that way they can stop
medical marijuana from
starting because it's a plant
as opposed to the slot coma and
things it helped. Doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter. They've proved it
to the cows come home. It's not just,
it's not,
it's not based on like logic reason
or something being fair and ethical.
It's based entirely on money,
entirely on money and that's so there's
my argument, there's more money in in,
in enforcing marijuana laws,
keeping people in jail than there is,
and I'll do you one better. There's an
economy based on enforcing marijuana laws.
If marijuana is responsible,
and this is a true fact,
was responsible for a large percentage
of people that are in federal prison,
a large percent,
more than 20% of all the people that
are in prison are in there because of
marijuana. It's growing it or selling
it or whatever. If that's the case,
all those people get out.
All those people now would not
get put in prison in the future.
No one would get put in prison that did
those things and now and raise their own
children. Christians will shrink and
there'll be less people in the prisons.
There'll be less prison guards, prison,
prison guard unions do not want that.
So prison guard unions
campaign and and and,
and use their money and their finances
to lobby heavily to make sure that
marijuana laws stay in place.
Once again,
an example of how Washington has become
an economy of influence. Once again,
why you gotta be,
you gotta know how the system works and
and the injustices it creates when a
special interest group can
affect other people's lives.
Because there's an economic advantage
in it. Even if it's an immoral,
I don't think anybody
has an argument with it.
The the argument with you
rather the argument is how,
where the question rather it becomes
how do you stop that from happening?
Take money out of politics.
Yeah, but who's a, you know,
there are ways to do it.
There are ways to do it.
It's not easy.
It's like taking that plastic
out of the bundle of the ocean.
It's essentially the same province unless
it has ideas and a lot of who the hell
is that guy and how, like how can
they kill him? His Mercedes, you know,
you're going to go right into a
tree at a hundred miles an hour.
Like Michael Hastings not hitting the
brakes. Right. Do you know about that? No.
You don't know about that? No. You don't
know about Michael Hastings now? Wow.
You're a weird guy, man. You
know about some strange shit,
but you don't know about some things.
Sometimes things are like
in the public consciousness,
yet completely blissfully unaware of
the Michael Hastings. Uh, conspiracy is,
he's a journalist for the rolling stone.
33 years old, cocky fuck, you know,
get getting people's faces on television
about generals and stuff about what
they're doing. And you guys are doing
this and that exposes a bunch of Shit.
Gets people in trouble. Is doing
an article about the CIA. Okay?
His car drives into a tree.
This is after he told everybody the
FBI's investigating him and his family.
And you know, if anybody, you
know, uh, gets contacted by
the FBI, just get a lawyer.
Like he's,
he's saying all this stuff like publicly,
his car goes 100 miles an hour without
ever hitting the brakes right into a tree.
Okay? He burst into flames and dies.
Okay. No, it doesn't hit the brakes.
It's four o'clock in the morning.
Judge drives straight into a tree.
They take his body cremated
against the wishes of his family.
Then the, uh, the,
the former security adviser think it
was the security advisor to Clinton and
Herbert Walker Bush.
Um,
he comes out and says that it's
possible to take over a car,
a modern car today,
including manipulate the steering cause
it's right here and the computers. Yes.
So he says you can turn your car into
a drone, Jesus and remote control,
a cost and suicide,
someone with it.
And so this guy who is spending all
of his time and all of his effort,
very high profile,
trying to take out the people in the
world that are the best at killing people
all of a sudden drives his car
100 miles an hour into a tree,
doesn't hit the brakes once.
And even people that aren't inclined to
subscribe to conspiracy theories just
go, wait a minute, what the fuck?
I've had some people that were there.
Very serious folks. Okay. And they've
sent me messages just saying, okay,
what the fuck is this? Like, I'm
not concerned about the Hastings.
So many people have written this message.
I'm not a conspiracy theorist,
but dot, dot, dot. And then sent me that.
I mean scholars like people that
I've met that are, you know,
have PhDs and they're looking at
this and they're going, whoa, whoa,
he's he.
He exposed some crazy shit fetched to
believe that there are people in power
that will kill you if you're
threatening their position.
It seems to me that's what
history would suggest,
but it goes along the lines
of what we're talking about,
how anonymous you can be about
what's possible. You know,
anybody at the NSA, I don't know
anybody. I don't know. Anyway,
I don't know anything about this guy guys.
I don't know any,
I don't know one person, so you
know. Yeah. I believe that there are,
there are probably people who could
manipulate a car. Yes, it can be done now.
It's a family. Pretty wild. No,
it's a fact. It can be done.
I want to get that Tesla, by the way,
whether it's been done is not a fact,
but it's a fact that it can be done.
There's absolutely, look at that.
Hacking a car is way too easy. These,
these guys who have looked at it,
it said that this is,
you know,
you're not talking about going past
faster than the speed of light.
You're talking about something that
can be done. And not only that,
a guy came out with an iPhone application,
a $25 iPhone application that can take
over your car. Come on. Yeah. Yeah.
Someone,
someone came up with an application for
a cell phone that can take over a car he
needs.
One of the reasons why he talked about it,
because he wanted to let people know
like, hey look, I made this like you guys,
look, I know that this is real.
Okay. I'm not trying to hurt anybody,
but I want everybody to
know that this is possible.
Talk about being able to steal
a car really easily. Yeah. Well,
a car is a computer, you know, and again,
it sort of goes to what we were
talking about about one day.
There's going to be a point in
time where money's not real.
There's also going to be a point in
time where objects aren't really there
because there are computers and you
gonna be able to control it all.
It's like it's really amazing. I
never, I never thought of that.
I'm literally looking at that test lab.
Want to get that electric car crazy.
So you should get an a 1970 Porsche.
I know cause they're always
updating that car there.
They're always downloading information
into it. That Tesla. Right.
You want a car with a carburetor
and that's just no anti Laos the gallon.
No,
the old Porsche's done but not as bad.
It's my car. What do you think of that?
You know a lot about cars. I
love Tesla. Well know the issue.
I mean yes or no. You can't have
it as a primary car. Your only car.
That's when the shit hits
the fan. You're stuck. Okay.
Gasoline is going to exist for a while.
Okay.
Even if there's some sort of a
pandemic walking dead type scenario,
you can be able to find, I haven't at
least have a gas pockets of gas. Yeah.
But the issue with these cars
right now is two fold. One,
there's not enough superstations
and what a superstition is,
you can go there and in 10 minutes they
can charge it like 50% it's pretty bad
ass. It only takes like 10 minutes. The
other way to do it, I think it's like,
I think it's within 30 minutes or an hour,
they get it up to like 90% but then to
get to that last the extra 10% it's quite
a bit more. It's a pain in
the deck, man. If you, if you,
if you're just driving back and forth
and you know you're going to park it in
your house every night and
commute, it goes about 300
miles and that's good. Yeah,
that's fine. Like for la traffic during
the day, that's fine. It'll work.
But if you want to go somewhere,
like if you want to go to Vegas,
you might not make it.
You're going to have to stop somewhere
along the line and charge your car and it
might take a half an hour. I'm getting
one cause I got to Vegas twice a year.
I'm getting the test. I mean,
if you're not in like a travel,
you're not going to go to Yosemite.
You're not going to drive up to San
Francisco. Yeah. Yeah. I get it.
It's a beautiful car. It's a beautiful
car. I interviewed Martine Rothblatt.
She um, is the, the woman who
she actually invented, um,
direct TV. She or I'm not directly
via XM radio, satellite radio. Wow.
And uh, had, uh, one of those things,
she remember those Tesla things
and I was like, Ooh, this is bad.
It's like this thing.
She's the one who there's a the in the
video for this new show that I'm doing.
Um, uh, she has a robot
made of her spouse.
It's called being a 48.
Her wife's name is Beena and she has
this been a 48 robot that's a head that
talks to you.
It's connected to a computer and you
talk to it and ask you questions and it
answers and responds and it's like,
this is like one step further
than the last one that she had,
but just one step further than
the previous one. I was like,
she's slowly but surely updating these
things until eventually it's a real robot.
Like eventually it's not just
going to be a robot of her spouse,
it's going to be hers, her
spouse, if destiny, this a,
it's, it's an inevitability,
but she had that debt. Bad Ass Tesla,
Tesla. Yeah. I, I'm, I want to get that.
It's a wicked car, man. It's fast too.
It's weird fast because it all
is like immediate and instant.
It's like there's no gears.
How long until the other car companies
come along and have their version of the
test because they, I think it's
selling really well. Pretty okay.
Pretty sure you did.
It would for sure.
What Tesla figured out was how to make a
car that's electric doesn't look like a
piece of shit. There were the first
ones with that. A bad ass car.
I'm not even in cars. You know
me, I drive the lame his cars.
I actually want one well that that
sports car, they have to, his wish.
That thing is fast,
but it's really rear weight bias because
of all the lithium ion batteries and
the trunk. There's a lot of
weight in the rear. That's that,
that write that sentence right there.
As a guy who knows cars,
it's very way by a set of lithium battery.
I'm like, all right. Yeah. All right.
Well, you know Porsche is
or rear by balanced. Um,
for the most part except for
the Cayman's and Boxsters,
which are actually the better design
cars if they're there in a really tricky
situation because the nine 11 since the
beginning when they first designed it,
they designed it with an engine that's
hung out behind the rear wheels.
Nobody else does that.
There's not another car that does that.
Everybody else does either
a mid engine format,
which means that the engine is on front
of the wheels or means it's in front of
the front wheels. Yeah. Which allows,
you know the weight in the front.
That's a good 50 50 distribution way.
The, we have the the front engine car.
That's why I like the Lexus Lfa. That's
super fast, crazy hyped up Lexus.
That was a front engine car. The Corvette
Zr one that's a front engine car,
but a lot of the exotics, like
Ferrari mid engine, the Nsx,
the Acura Nsx, that was a mid
engine car for for balance issues,
just like the Cayman and the Boxster.
But Porsche keeps their
engine now back still,
so they have to like engineer all
these ways to avoid what's called lift
throttle oversteer because of the fact
that you have this weight in the back as
you're going around a corner,
if you let off the brakes,
your front end comes up and then
the asin goes forward, spins.
So you have to keep the front end down
so you have to keep accelerating into a
corner because you've got this massive
pendulum behind you because if you know
how to use it, it's wicked. Yeah.
So if you know how to use it,
you actually know how to
accelerate our corners better.
You know how to judge it and gauge it,
but not in that fucking Tesla.
Okay,
you got a bunch of batteries back then
we'll scas tires. It doesn't have like,
you know, like if you look at a
Porsche like that, my gt three, the Rs,
those tires are like 15
inches. Why they're fucking
giant in the back. That is,
I read that right? That Cory, how about
that? It's a race car. Yeah it is.
But that's the point is like it's designed
and knows how to deal with this rear
weight. I don't think the Tesla
has that sporty as far as like,
I think there's actually been tests. I
think Chris Harris was one of my favorite,
uh, automotive journalist does a lot of
cool videos on cars. They took a test,
so around a track and I was like sliding
all over the place. Yeah. Well I don't,
I don't try. I mean, what are you doing?
You going on and track or are
you just driving it around town?
It's going to drive around and
you're not even looking at that one.
You're not looking at the little little
sports car one, looking at the big one.
The big ones. Beautiful. Yeah, but there's
only them. And then there's the Karma,
the Fisker Karma. But I think they went
out of business. I think they did. Yeah.
Do you know what happened
with them? No. Listen to this.
They had a gang of them parked,
uh,
on the docks when hurricane sandy hit
and the water came up really high and it
flooded the docs.
And so these cars got
flooded and they exploded.
They started exploding
and then they realize, oh,
you just got this massive electrical
power source and a water gets on it and it
explodes. Good thing we found out that
hurricane sandy may cause I can see it.
I'm trying [inaudible] water.
Yeah.
You can be driving through standing
water in your fucking car would explode.
Look at that. Those are those cars
they burnt to the ground. Yeah.
They exploded in bursts.
I think it was like 15 cars
or something crazy like that.
Does it say in the article how many cars?
They lost a shit load of them.
They all got wet and exploded. I
haven't, I, speaking of explosive,
watch how I might watch. I changed the
explosive new show coming out. No, no,
not that I will be at the Schomburg
again, Bro. No. But here's my question.
I'm Rory Macdonald. Uh, Jake Allen
versus weekend sign. What's your call?
Chaos. That's my call. Who the hell knows?
Wicked. There's those are two pit bulls,
man. Yeah, those are
two elite of the elite.
Ellenberger has a lot more experience
with high level competition though.
He's soft. He's fun named mark or all
kinds of guys. Knock Nate Marquardt silly,
you know, I mean he's a beast. Jake
Ellenberger is a fucking beast.
Knocked out Jake shields.
Ellenberger is a motherfucker man.
He hits hard.
He's fast as shit.
And the way he took on Nate Marquardt
opened up a lot of people's eyes.
He's real dangerous. How did he do
that? I mean it made sense. A question.
Real good question. Especially when
you look at Nate's previous fight,
while the previous fight
was not a good one,
he fought Terex Avidyne and
lost his title. Got Leg kicked,
70 just leg kicked the shit out of him.
I don't think he had fought real smart.
He didn't plan for that or
something, you know. Well I think,
I don't think you can take
it away from Saffadi Dean.
Cause I think he fought the worst case
scenario fight when you fighting like a
really what staffing is,
is a very technical kickboxer.
He's very technical.
He does things the right way.
Marquardt is athletic and
powerful and explosive.
But no disrespect his camp,
I don't think he's trained in the,
like the technical level of [inaudible]
70 was like a real professional kickbox
right.
And his Moitai his like his kickboxing
is very much on point and if you think
you could eat leg kicks from a
guy like that, you're mistaken.
And there's a lot of guys that are real
good that especially mark hard coming
off of that fight with Tyron Woodley and
Tyron Woodley's a motherfucker, right?
So he knocks out Tyron Woodley with this
video game combination of punches that
looks just spectacular.
He's on top of the world.
He thinks he's the crusher at one seven
he's going to beat everyone's ass.
And how Safford ain't gonna fuck with him.
Sure.
[inaudible] just starts kicking that leg
man. Slowly but surely. I mean when he,
when he fought Jose Aldo,
I'm are watching and I was there for,
actually I think I watched on,
we did stand up that night and I watched
Frankie Edgar get kicked a couple of
times by that crazy Jose Aldo leg kick.
And guess what he did the third
time he dove into a double leg,
literally dove into that
like no hesitation is like,
oh you want to sound like Wayne and
then guess what Jose Aldo stopped leg
kicking him.
I couldn't believe that.
That's when I looked at Frankie
at your house. Like you are a,
you're such a Badass that
you took that leg kick away.
Cause Jose Aldo ruins careers
with that fun. He does. Yeah.
If you stand in front of them and
that's some, well it's, you know what?
It's the evolution of the sport. People
realizing that people use to old shit.
You know that was one of the number one
criticisms that are get from people that
I bring up. Leg kicks too much.
Like why hasn't he leg kicking?
Why does he led kicking?
I was like,
well this cause you've never
been leg kicked if you've
been leg kicked correctly.
Like we're starting to see it slowly
but surely all these various techniques
entering into MMA, like we didn't see
nearly as many head kicks in the past.
Like the early days it was very rare,
but now people will kick your
people and knocking people out.
This is stuff that I've been calling for
for like the longest time and it's not
because I'm just,
you know,
looking for some unrealistic
aspect of the sport to emerge. No,
it's because they're super effective.
So we get like gone like Aldo that shows
that like in the fight with your riot
faber, perfect example, Uriah Faber,
if you never followed it for like
weeks after that fight, he was fucked.
I talked to leg was twice the
size. He said, he told me, he said,
I thought I was going to faint.
It was so, it hurts so badly.
I thought it was going to faint in the
ring. And that's an the, I'm sorry, tough.
I'm if I'm, if I'm, yeah,
he's so tough. He's an animal.
I don't know if that's exactly what
I said. We talk about it and that's,
I think he used the word faint
and I was like, that's, that's a,
that's a warrior that a lot
of people would have quit
flavor. By the way, I make an
argument. He broke both his hands on,
on Mike Brown's head and kept fighting
and was using his by the top second
round. He's the toughest son of a bitch.
He had a fight three rounds, three,
four and five with two broken hands.
He's a beast.
And Mike Brown's a fucking beast.
Imagine being stuck in that guy.
This is after the guy knocks you senseless
and takes your title in the previous
fight and then you got to fight the next
fight with him with two broken hands.
Good luck. Yeah, good luck.
It's a tough man sport, but so,
so Ellenberg Ellenberger and, and
it's look groin. Mcdonald's. I'm sad.
And why the fuck dude? He's a bad
motherfucker. He's super technical.
He's super technical and driven
and he's psycho. He is, isn't here.
Roy McDonald definitely has a screw loose.
He gets in this case and he just
stares. He's just, he's just real man.
That's what he is. He's the real
deal. He's a fucking killer.
He's coming to get you. He's not, yeah,
they ain't playing no games in and
he might not get you if you know,
you might be able to get him,
but he's gonna he's gonna get better.
If you do get him,
he's going to go back to the drawing
board and come back better. I mean,
he's been gotten before,
but I liked Carlos condit called conduit
beat him and stopped him when he was
younger. And guess what? He came back
after that and was even scarier, you know,
and he calls out Carlos
condit was like his,
his lips are trembling and shit when
he talks about conduct and you're like,
oh Jesus, like that's another guy.
I have tremendous respect for.
Carl Carlos continent. He's a
beast. I think he's so good.
He's so good that George Saint
Pierre fight man, he almost got him.
He was never head kick. He never loses
his composure. Man Con it is very special.
He's tough as shit. Tough as
nails. And he's always in shape,
like five round conditioning shape.
Kids just started built like a tennis pro.
Yeah. He's not like the most athletic guy,
you know. He doesn't move the quickest.
He's doesn't have the most power.
You know, he's just an animal smart.
He's a smart, smart fighter. Never
loses his cool, tough as shit.
But there Roy McDonald kid a Katz,
he's no joke there as the first time he's
fought a guy like Ellenberger though.
I mean, you gotta think he beat the most
impressive victories of risk career,
whether it's a Nate Diaz.
Nate is essentially 155 pounder.
Or Bj Penn. Bj Penn was hung
out. Just 155 pounder. No,
he's the one 55 he was the one
that you've had a champion. I know.
Hard time probably suck.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
He had a hard time making one 55 was,
that's why I stopped doing it.
It's why he went up to
one 70 but I mean he's,
these guys are nothing
compared to Ellenberger.
Ellenberger is a legit one 70 and
he's a crusher. He's a scary one.
70 he's the one 70 and it puts you
guys in la La land with one punch.
So it's a really interesting fight.
Very interesting and a lot.
What's really crazy is although
Ellenberger has definitely fought like the
higher competition at one 70,
Rory is actually ranked higher than
him by a lot of people. And uh,
is the favorite coming into this
fight just based on talent alone,
based on people watching them take apart
guys like chain mail is take apart Bj
like GSPs training partner and I believe
not anymore, but I was going to say,
correct me if I'm wrong, he said he
would fight GSP I believe. Right?
I think they stopped training together.
I daws yeah,
because he kind of alluded to the fact
that he would be willing to fight you.
I shouldn't say this until I'm, I talked
to both of them. Are either one of them,
cause I haven't talked to him about this,
but what I've read recently is that he's
been training and like the other side
of the gym is that like,
you know,
they realize that eventually
they're going to find if this,
I mean it doesn't want to,
you know,
but eventually he said there's two guys
you wouldn't fight GSP and Weidman.
Chris Weidman is also,
they're trained together.
There's a video of a Rory and
Weidman training together. But,
but who knows if that's even true.
I think weapons bigger isn't it?
I mean just this frame and
everything and not that much bigger.
You watch the two of them spar together.
It's kind of shocking. Really. Roy,
he's a big kid. He's
a big kid. I think he,
I mean he's walks around over 200 pounds
for it starts as cut when he gets down
to one 70 he does it like,
you know he's won 70 he's fucking shred.
I have a question cause I've,
I've seen this guy trained Hector lumbar,
it's going to suck down to one 70 what
are you talking about? No, it's not a,
what are you talking about at all?
How is he going to do that?
So are you talking about he's not, he's
five seven. He's thick. He's muscular.
But by the way, it should have been
fighting at one seventies entire career.
Really?
Yeah,
100% when you see a guy that is competing
in a smaller organization and crushing
people and then you see him fight in the
UFC and you see him start losing and he
gets out muscled by big guys like
Tim Boetsch and you, you know,
I realize that he's losing the
tuition Okami and you go, oh,
I see what's going on. You don't
belong in that weight class. Wow.
Like you're too small for that weight
class. That's so shocking to me.
It gives me so much more respect.
I've seen him training.
I was down in age is an animal. He's
the biggest, thickest guy. I mean,
I looked at him, no, no, no, before I knew
him. Anyway. You're saying crazy talk.
He's one. He's five seven. That's 170
pound man's friend. He's a fit guy.
If you're that Short,
I guess you have to suck down because
you don't have the length. When you talk,
look, look at his build and that
by the what in other, by the way,
another problem with a build like
that is it makes for explosive power.
No doubt about it,
but all that muscle requires fuel you.
You really shouldn't have that much
builder muscle on your body because as a
fighter that's not helping you.
It's not.
It's that that stuff's weighing you down.
It's causing you to have this massive
engine that you have to fuel three round
or five round fight, five
rounders, especially five for
five rounds. Five meg ones.
Yeah. If you look at the best fighters,
like the high level five round guys,
they're there. They're in good
shape, they're in great shape,
but they never have that
level of musculature. I mean,
he's a thick fucking God.
He's going to fight and mark core.
That's going to be crazy.
If I can't wait to see,
well,
it's going to be interesting to
see how he deals with the cut.
It's probably be a reasonable,
I fought at one 85 and one of the,
some of the reasons some people just,
they don't perform well when
they're dieting. They don't
perform art. It's also,
it kills your confidence and training.
You start losing weight,
you start feeling weaker, you start
feeling like shit you want to eat,
you want to say fucking I'm going back up.
But one 85 you know,
and it depends on how much weight
is he going to actually cut.
And as he'd done it before,
has he ever cut a shitload of weight
right before a fight before, you know,
cause a lot of these guys, the week of
the fight, they're cutting like 20 pounds.
Right? And a lot of it's [inaudible]
the shit out of themselves.
They feel terrible. They live it to like
some of them black out in the back room.
Like we've seen guys that like they had
to get the flight canceled because they,
they cut too much weight and then they're
like fucking fall down and bang their
head when they're, when they're out
back there talking to the doctor.
It's not just happen.
Once you like the idea of someone
like being really sick before a fight.
It's happened many times,
right?
Like 24 hours before you're supposed to
go into a cage and throw kicks at each
other and you can't even walk,
you know that's people's lungs collapse.
All kinds of weird crazy shit. Yeah.
That happened to Rory. Mark, I'm sorry.
Mark Marcum,
when he fought Dan hard try to get
down to one 70 he was a big boy too.
Big Country Fed five foot 11
and a half fucking gorillas try.
I remember Pat Miletich introduced me
to them once a long time ago at the hard
rock and like this is my best new up and
coming one 70 I was like one 70 yeah.
How has that guy won 70 that's
a football player. Yeah.
Well how about Anthony
Rumble Johnson sucking down.
I did a movie with a fighting heavyweight
now walking around at two 30 and the
set of warrior, I was like, you're going
to suck down to what? What did you say?
Well, he fought Arlovski beat our Alaska
as a heavyweight. Yes, he did. Oh my God.
I almost knocked him out in the first
round. Wow. Sad. Arlovski's staggered,
broke his jaw,
had him all fucked up and the first
room and Arlovski managed to hang on and
lose a decision. I have, that's the one
thing about when I watched her last scan,
how athletic it was.
He ultimately didn't seem to have the,
he didn't really become the UFC fighter.
He was supposed people thought
he was going to be, um,
well he was the champion.
I mean,
at one point in time he's just scariest
guy in the planet and our, you know,
he was knocking people out with one
punch, but then he lost it. Tim Silvia.
And then he came back and they,
you know,
they fought again and Sylvia beat
him again. It's like, they're like,
it's one of those things where you could
only stay at the top for so long and
then it's the top in relationship
to where the sport is at the moment.
So in, in that moment when our Alaska
was the UFC heavyweight champion,
that's where the sport
was with a sport was,
was it was at this spot where this guy
who was this big super fast athletic
kickboxer with lightning lightning quick
reflexes was knocking guys like Paul
boy and tello silly, you know, he was
knocking guys silly as a heavyweight.
He was a super athlete and he was
really like moved really well.
But I started getting tagged,
he's lost a few by Kao and then he loses
his confidence and he's sorta getting
code on a regular basis.
He gets cared by fate or he gets
carried by a couple of other guys,
including guys that he's supposed
to beat. And you know, it becomes a,
it becomes a real problem with
confidence and everything else. Yeah.
Brett Rogers Kaos him and like the first
30 seconds of their fight just storms
after Maceio some, you know, it's like
he had like a real series of problems.
He was fighting fader
and was like going fight,
punch for punch with fade or for most of
the first round and then tries as crazy
flying knees. Leon. Yeah. That
felt like a lack of confidence.
Like he tried to rush the fight, you
know, jumping into that, I don't know.
It's a lack of confidence.
I think he just did something stupid.
He just got crazy and he didn't,
didn't respect the guys power
or he just took a while chance.
Sometimes people take wild chances as Jon
Jones going to go to a heavyweight, uh,
he doesn't have to, he can fight it. Two
Oh five he can, he makes two oh five.
I mean,
I think he's a big kid.
I think one day he's probably going
to be the heavyweight, you know,
shouldn't say heavyweight champion.
I should say a heck.
I get through Cain Velasquez
and some other guys.
He's going to have to be a
heavy and stuff like that.
But it'll also be interesting when you
see him fight as a heavyweight because
you know,
how will he do against a really big guy
that's naturally larger than him that
that could never fight at two oh five
with and there are those guys like,
you know, like Shane Collins is a perfect
example. Shankar fight and two oh five.
Okay. He's got fucking cinder blocks
because he calls hands Colin. He's all,
his bones are giant thick. He's like
an ogre dude. You know, it's like,
that's how he's built. He's
a giant motherfucker, you
know, even when he's lean,
he's like two 50, something like that.
And there's a big fucking bone guy.
It was two 85 I was hanging out with them
on the, the ultimate fighter is to 85.
Yeah, but when you've seen them, you're,
you're seeing him after years of football.
Like there's a picture of him,
you're seeing them after years of flip
all he had like serious back injuries,
man, he had a, he had
a couple of surgeries.
He to retire on a podcast stenosis
and a stenosis is a short,
this, the, the, uh, the
canal where the nerves are,
starts getting impinged and the disc
start degrading and you start like getting
numbness and serious, serious
issue for a, for combat athletes,
if you,
you'd taken a lot of shots and you're
starting your disc start degenerating and
you start getting numbness and losing.
That's Bas Rutten's issue as well.
It's why he's had two neck surgeries and
it's why he has one arm. It's atrophied.
It's all the nerves. The nerves are
getting impacted, they're getting smushed,
they're getting cutoff is nothing they
can do. Oh, that's a fucking huge problem.
You could have surgeries and shed.
I mean,
people have surgeries where they try to
do at AU naturale they try to do it with
yoga and stretching and try to,
but the cat fight during that time,
you have to retire, you have to
retire and you have to stop fighting.
And you know,
I think means Carlin's got a family and a,
I talked to him after his last surgery.
Which about the one,
I don't know if he's had one sense,
but the last surgery
I talked to him about,
it was like about a year
and a half ago. It was, no,
it was a little over a year ago
because it was at the UFC expo,
which just happened last
couple of weeks ago. And, uh,
he had just gotten out of
the surgery and he's like,
I don't know when I'm going to be able to
fight again. You know, I'm in training,
I'm trying, I'm trying to get it
together. He's like, but it's hard.
Well, I just talked to him,
um, recently, um, and he, he,
uh, about, uh, actually a
week ago and he, um, you know,
he's just adjusting to retirement. It's
really hard for a guy like that who is,
you know,
King of the beasts to have to retire
and you've got a lot to go back to.
He's got a family, he's electrical
engineer. He's got a career. But he,
when I talked to him,
he was,
I'm an oil field and he was looking around
and they was doing some work. And, uh,
it's, it's, it's a big transition, a
big emotional transition for, for Shane,
you know?
Yeah. Well it has to man.
It, you know, it has to be,
it's really difficult to do,
to transition from anything where you're
a professional athlete with a finite
career, whether it's basketball
or baseball or football,
they all go through it and
they all go through it.
But for combat athletes it's even harder
because a lot of times when you're
going through it, your body is just
done. When it's over, you're done.
I mean, you have like some serious
fucking problems, you know,
all these guys are getting their knees
fixed and they're back fixed and it's
like you can't train any train that
hard all the time. I'm sorry, but your,
your body's made a cartilage and
bone in it and it grinds away man.
And there's so many fighters that have
like artificial discs or disks that are a
few ways to metamorris.
There was that guy who won his match.
Braulio was tema and he's got a, he's
got an artificial disc in his neck. Yeah.
It's like a titanium. Yes, yes,
they do it. They do it in Europe.
They don't do it in America,
but they do in Europe. Wow.
At least I don't think they do it.
And how does that, how does that,
how does he find that?
I guess he looked tough to me.
He's still a bad motherfucker. And
with this, his disk, I mean he uh,
he trains really hard and I know he wins
World Championships and he beats like
top, top, top level guys. I like
that community Jitsu community.
I had a really good feeling being at
Metamorris that that community is, um,
maybe it's a Brazilian thing.
I just like them. They just,
they just seem like a tight group.
Well,
we've talked about this
in the podcast before.
The people that do Jujitsu and
get really good at Jujitsu,
they have healthy egos because you
have to tap out on a regular basis.
You have to, unless you're Hixon Gracie
and no one's tapped you since 1980,
you getting tapped out on a regular basis.
It's just a part of the game.
You're going in there. You're rolling
with, you know, Bill Cooper and Solow,
he barrow and you rolling with a bunch
of savages, they're strangling you.
And that's part of Jujitsu.
You know, you get tapped.
I mean I've been tagged by blue belts.
You put yourself in a bad position.
Somebody catches some.
If you're dumb,
you know you don't tap and then you
get your arm broken. Cause guess what?
A 200 pound man who's a blue belt
who catches an armbar correctly.
And if you are tired and you
know it gets full extension,
you have to fucking tap. That's
it's what it is. It is what it is.
And when you're doing that on
a high level for a long time,
you get a healthy ego because you're
always getting your ass kicked.
You get your ass handed to
you and training, especially
when you do like those,
um, those drills where you
do like at a 10th planet,
we'll do like nine minutes a live sparring
and then you have 30 seconds rest for
a minute, rest rather, uh,
where everybody grabs a drink and then
you go to the next person for nine
minutes. That's it. In two persons,
you're doing 18 minutes of co
Hanahan fucking combat a lot of fun.
You're going to get tapped.
You're just going to get tapped if you,
unless you're the best guy, unless
you're Eddie Bravo or one of the bad.
And even Eddie gets tapped occasionally
if he goes with his black belts or as
brown belts, maybe even,
you know, when you're,
when you're doing it on a
regular basis and you're tired,
you're going to get fucking tapped.
And if you don't do it on
a regular basis and tired,
then you're not going to
know the proper defense.
You're not going to know how to handle
yourself and defend yourself when you're
in a shitty situation. Watching
I eco get tapped by, um,
[inaudible] I mean I buy kron Gracie.
Yeah.
And you could see the disappointment
on his face because he's so good. Yeah.
Anything else? But it was just a, yeah.
It's like it happens to everybody.
You make one mistake, one mistake.
See, yeah. A guy like Cron,
he gets a hold of your neck that's and
let it go. He's trained by the master,
by the masters. And legitimate. I mean
he's, he's going to all like he's,
he trains with all the best
guys on a regular basis.
He's constantly got
killers coming to his gym.
I mean Henry Gracie telling me eating
in a on a high level on a regular basis.
Yeah.
I think it was Hannah said,
he goes when he rolls with
[inaudible] and he said it's,
he's fighting for his life.
The last time I was nobody,
nobody puts him through the ringer.
Like that guy just centers big when
your dad is Hixon fucking Gracie.
Just think about the amount of knowledge
that he must've related to his son.
If you don't know Jujitsu,
you know Hixon Gracie is like,
there's not a whole lot of sports where
there's one guy who is universally
recognized as the mother fucker.
It's like the motherfucker
of motherfuckers when it
comes to Jujitsu is Hixon
Gracie because if you talked to anybody,
if you talked to hoist Gracie,
if you talk to any of these guys, and
this is going on by the way, by the way,
by the way,
in 1993 when the UFC was at first he
said when hoists was beating everybody in
UFC one, it was like huge. Should
see my brother Hicks, um, my brother,
he and kills me and he used
to talk about that. You know,
the moment somebody beats me,
you're in trouble because then my brother,
he Exxon is going to join and I remember
Hixon if you watch the early days of
the UFC or that he was fighting in
Japan valley to doe, that's the,
you want to see a documentary
that'll get you into Jujitsu choke.
It's you and I watched it together.
Kit Document and I want to have to go
that we were so quiet, we were selling,
I think we went out to dinner
afterwards when we were both,
so we were so awed and quiet.
I remember UN where he was talking about
how fear and intelligence are closely
related and you went like this. You just
said you couldn't help yourself song.
Anyway, listen to what he's saying, man.
I was like, I am. I haven't said a thing,
dude. You'd have to shout at me. We
were both so bunched up about it.
And by the way started
just by look how handsome.
I forget. Incredible flexibility in a
Speedo by the way, on, on, on in Malibu.
He said, by the way, I don't care. You
don't care cause Hixon brings out the,
by the way, I got to pee right
now. Go ahead and pay. It's uh,
it's amazing when there's one guy
like that though that stands out.
And I think one of the things,
go ahead and pee.
I'll keep talking as if you were here.
What? We'll talk about everything. Go Pee.
Um,
one of the things about it,
a guy like Hixon that's so fascinating
is that what separates him from everybody
else is not just his physicality.
Like he's obviously very physical.
He's got great flexibility.
So obviously very strong.
If you looked at the old videos of
hoists, Gracie, when hoist won the UFC,
one of the things about hoist that
was so impressive was that he wasn't a
physically imposing guy.
Hoists was like 175 pounds.
He was very thin and he
didn't have big muscles.
Hixon on the other hand is built
like a Greek God. So it's not,
he's not like muscular,
like say like a George Saint Pierre.
It was like more like a
gymnast or something like that.
Doesn't make any sense because George
has kind of been like a gymnast,
but he was like a little
bit less muscular. Um,
but he's a strong looking dude,
like very obvious. But his,
his thing was also the mind and also yoga.
It wasn't just his technique
and his physicality.
It was also the fact that he
was like a recognized Yogi.
So when everybody else was
like doing steroids and,
and running hills and shit
with weights on their back and,
and doing all this, uh,
you know, all these, uh,
different kinds of a
bodybuilding sort of things.
Hickson's doing this weird thing with
his stomach where he's sucking in his
diaphragm doing this,
uh,
these yoga breathing technique
that's really freaky to watch.
We can pull his stomach and in control
his breath in this really astounding way.
He's also insanely flexible,
you know,
like in every single way
in every single position.
And is his yoga is like one of the
more unique aspects of him as a martial
artist because he can move in such
strange ways because of the yoga.
Like it's very rare that you get a guy
who's really strong and really flexible
and that's what he was on top of that.
His fucking dad was Aly oh Gracie,
who was maybe the most important
man in the history of martial arts.
You're talking about a guy who in Jesus,
I mean,
he was doing these Jujitsu
matches in the 1940s.
He was learning these techniques
that were taught to him by my Ada,
by these, uh, these Japanese
judo guys fought this Guy Kimora,
which is a where that famous shoulder
lock, his name, that Kimora shoulder lock.
He fought Eylea Gracie and Eylea let the
guy break his arm instead of tapping.
That's how bad ass he is.
Imagine growing up and that's your dad.
Your Dad decides to let some guys snap
is on chicken wing because he doesn't
want to tap.
So he learned how to do small man Jujitsu.
He Changed Jujitsu because he was a
little guy. He was only like 140 pounds.
So because of that he was scrapping
with all these big dudes. He had to,
what he called Cook them, he had to let
them cook. He couldn't just eat them raw.
He had a slowly tire,
these bitches,
all the cooking that call them cooking
though. He had a slowly tie them out.
So he developed like a very extensive
repertoire of techniques to use from the
guard and he also developed the concept
of protecting yourself in a real self
defense situation. Elio,
Gracie, long before the UFC,
he was putting himself in these valley
Tudo matches where he would go out there
and just Duke it out with dudes like,
and they would like they,
they'd put on these events in Brazil
and he would have these time limits.
And then his, his cousin, uh, Carlos, uh,
well was, there was a bunch of different,
there was his brother is Carlson,
Gracie was his cousin and crossing Gracie
became like the most winningest guy.
He was a bigger,
stronger guy.
And he came in and some of the
guys that Leo couldn't be beat and,
but Leo developed like not just a system
of Jujitsu but a series of killers that
we're sons. I mean his sons
or house and Gracie Horian,
Gracie hoists, Gracie Hixon,
Gracie Heuler, Gracie.
I mean there's never been a motherfucker
ever who developed that many killers as
sons.
And then those guys go off and branch
out out into the world and spread you
Jitsu. The most astounding family in
the history of martial arts. Barn done.
None is the Gracie family changed.
They changed it all.
They changed and the and the, the grand
put truth to and you know what I mean.
All of a sudden all your Kung fu
and everything is no good in here.
My friend and it boils down in my
opinion all to the grandmaster Caz,
but his, it was his bro.
It was Carlos for sure.
Carlos Gracie was also very
important in the development of it,
but Leo was out there, Duke in and
out with guys and he was small.
He was a small guy and because of that
and because of the impact of his sons,
I think he's like the most important
figure in the history of martial arts.
I would, I would argue that that's,
that's, I don't think there's any denying.
Once the UFC came along and his
son who wasn't even the best one,
was killing everybody. He sent in his
son. That wasn't even the best one.
Credible and that incredible.
I remember him being this wrestling
wizard and I was watching him and I was
watching him go on. I that
doesn't look like, I don't know,
it looks like kind of bad wrestling.
I don't really get it. Well,
you let guys take them down. Fight off his
back. Maybe fod, Dan Severn, Dan Severen,
250 fucking pound giant wrestler.
Awesome.
Take down when he gets caught a triangle
by this little skinny guy and Ken
shamrock and this weird thing,
a weird,
he got him with each choke choked him
as gay. Yeah. Look Hoists Gracie was,
that was an important
moment for martial arts.
And there was the first time also that
we realized that like in the movies,
it was always a little dude with
skill that was beating the fuck out.
All of these guys. It was always Bruce
Lee. It was small but fast as fuck.
And using his martial arts defeat much
larger Sammo hung looking dudes, you know,
or uh, who was the guy with a big
muscles? All Bolo. Bolo Young, right?
So you know,
and Chuck Norris member when Chuck Norris
and him duked it out narcis bigger and
stronger and Bruce Lee fucked him up.
But in the real world,
that didn't really happen that often.
And the real world,
those big guys sorta got ahold of you.
Beat your fucking head in oak pulp.
That's more of what most of
us saw on a regular basis.
So then when you have the craziest
event in the history of martial arts,
this is cage fighting event where
you're going to lock all these different
styles in it.
Find out who's the best,
the odds that this one really technical
small guy I was going to win there were
astronomical as far as the martial
arts community was concerned.
They thought that the biggest
karate guy was gonna win.
You know just your biggest
guy who can kick them out.
A lot of guys who were karate guys thought
they were going to win because they'd
never been tested.
A lot of guys like judo,
judo guys and they're karate Kung Fu guys
and get in there a Krav Maga guys and
they actually believed because they had
been training so long that they were
going to win until all of a sudden
they get caught in these weird jokes.
Armbars punched in the face.
It was this a whole,
well this is how little they knew about
it. When guys got into certain positions,
it got to a point where guys
going into certain positions,
they thought there was no
escape in those positions.
They would just tap out when rem co
Pardo who is like a really tough Guy Fart
Marco who os all Marco
who Austin was mount him,
Marco mountain him and he's like, well
the basically the fights over so he taps,
he taps some Marco mounts him like that's
like a regular basis that like happens
all the time in high level fights.
I think about Anderson sell his first
round with shell son and she'll mounted
him for like most of the first round
in the second fight and then in the,
in the second round came back and
stopped him and knocked him out.
Like the idea that a guy mounts you
in a fights over. Like that's how,
that's how much MMA and that's how much
Jujitsu has come along since the 1990s.
We know that Anderson's going to
fight Chris Weidman again. Yes.
It's going to be December 29th you coming.
Uh,
I'm definitely come doing the
Mirage night calling cal me in and,
and but the thing is that um,
it's going to be,
you did see how dominant and son was
when he got into Chris's head and then to
fool around to that extent was just so,
well I wouldn't say was he was dominant.
He was definitely hitting Weidman and he
was hitting him with a lot of leg kicks.
Yeah,
that was the big issue.
And that was one thing that John
Danaher was concerned about,
talked to don her after the fights with
this is how much of a mastermind John
Danaher is. He's the Jujitsu
coach and I love John by the way.
He's a brilliant investor,
John Brilliant Guy.
But right after Weidman just knocks
out Anderson, I, I go up to them, I go,
congratulations.
And he goes very concerned about the,
about metal leg kicks he was
taking, he was our, he just,
I understood the next
fight inside the octagon.
He was thinking even the most spectacular
result possible and knocked down
Anderson Silva and he's like,
well,
I'm not happy with the amount
of live kicks he was taking.
He wasn't defending the lake
kicks correctly like this.
Guys like on it as well.
He should be. You have to be in that game.
That can't be any, you're the best kid.
No one's ever going to beat Ya.
He recognizes like this played out great,
but we got an issue because Anderson
Silva seems to be able to see everything
you're doing.
It's going to be real interesting to see
what happens in the sacrifice can do.
It's interesting to see if
Anderson showboats at all. Again,
it's going to be interesting to
see how Weidman approaches it,
how company is now Wyman's
getting better all the time.
The fact that he knocked out Anderson
Silva in his 10th fucking professional
fight is insane. It's, it's
also a testament to Anderson
Silva fucking around.
Not really because Weidman had him down
in the ground and had him in a heel hook
long before that.
What's going to happen in the second
fight would've Weidman is six inches
further down the knee when he wraps up
that heel hook and what if he uses the
legs properly next time and laces them
differently and locks up his hips so that
he can't roll out of it and then rips
his knee apart who some are called Horace
style. I would tell you
this, I would tell you this,
Anderson has met and dealt with
wrestlers that are as good or better.
No, you're wrong. You're wrong, you're
wrong. It's bad. It's good at wrestling.
It's better freestyle,
Russell Weidman's better four time
all American and not only that,
not only is he better,
he's bigger and faster and scarier
because he's got vicious knockout power,
which is what shell son had never had
because he knocked out Uriah hall.
That kid who was the standout
in the ultimate fighter
that the one by we'll kick
the last ultimate fighter.
He knocked that guy out with a left hook,
the same left hook that he knocked out
Anderson with. He knocks people out.
He knocked out Munoz with an elbow.
He smashed his people.
He also puts people to sleep. You
can't take anything away from that kid.
He won that fight because Anderson Silva
fucked up and he didn't respect him.
He dropped his hands and he and he got
clipped. But Wyman still won that fight.
There's a lot of fucking people that
have been in that same situation wouldn't
have been able to do shit.
He was able to do shit because he's
a forest Griffin and Damien Maia,
he's a motherfucker dude. He's the
real deal. The question is though,
is Anderson more of a motherfucker and
more of the real deal and what Anderson
are we going to see in that second fight?
Cause then that second fight,
he's going to be so goddamn motivated.
There's nobody like Anderson Silva.
I mean he's just so far and
away better than it seems.
I don't know how he does it. I just,
I, it's the craziest thing. You know,
he's just very good athlete.
He's incredible what he does.
He's been doing it forever. He's a
master at Moitai, a master at Jujitsu.
He's a master at MMA. He's like faster.
We still lost and that's why it's, it's a,
there's a beautiful lesson
in there for fighters.
There's a beautiful lesson
about human human beings.
Even the greatest ever. If you clip
them on the chin, they go on conscience.
He's going out. That's just how it
is with Mamah. Cheney is going out.
We ran out of time, man. Fucking shit.
You're the best. I love you. I love you.
We're going November shop this weekend
come and then November where on meter
again and do another after. We're
hunters now. When are we doing it?
Well doing it Toronto. Uh, ninth
the 19th nine September 19th. Yeah.
Kalyn and I are doing, um, I don't
know what the fuck it's called.
The Sony something or something.
And Toronto. What is it called?
Did I tell you ready? Whatever
it is, you'll find it. It's
almost sold out though.
I should tell you that.
It's a,
I think last time I checked
there was like three quarters.
It's only been on sale for like a week,
but it's a,
it's already like three quarters sold out
or at least half sold out or something.
It's the Sony Center for the Performing
Arts. I fucking love Toronto.
It's one of my favorite places
to go. Oh, the updated. Okay.
There's still some tickets left.
Um, the Sony Centre is a new place.
I usually do a Massey hall, but that's
the same weakest just for laughs. The,
the festival they have up there. Canada
is just, everybody loves to come to,
I love Canada. I love
performing in Canada. It's so
much fun. I'm doing it. Uh,
Calgary and um, November,
October Bryan Callen Dotcom,
c a l l e n.com.
And follow him on Twitter because every
time I look at his Twitter numbers,
I get sad. You need something? I count
how many accounts show or you won the,
are you on the Twitter all the time?
You'd be tweeting all the time. Yeah.
I'm just, I'm not staying on
top of that shit. My podcast,
I've been doing thanks to you. I think
I've got 75 episodes now. Beautiful.
Great guests. So a township.
It's a fun podcast.
It's fun podcasts and I do get a lot of
interesting motherfucker, Joe Rogan. Well,
it's, you know, it's not you look,
it's thanks to all these people that were
sort of connected to online. We're all,
we're all sort of connected to all these
interesting people that are willing to
now do the show and then you get more
and then you help them and like I just
want,
my job is just to inspire.
I just want to take young people and show
him that there's a world out there of
people who can teach you stuff. I'm
getting a sleep expert on, I'm getting,
I just love doing it. I
like getting, you know,
I said I think I'm getting
Jared diamond on who?
Who won a Pulitzer prize for guns, germs
and steel and blow. It was great book.
What I'm realizing is
all these guys write,
these great books are sitting around in
a room writing and they liked to talk to
people and I'll get a chance to his mind,
why wouldn't they want
to teach people like me?
I learn every time I do something like
go check it out. You fucks my shit.
My new show airs tomorrow night,
which is,
I'm the 24th of July on the Scifi channel
and it's called Joe Rogan questions,
everything. And Duncan Trussell
is in the first episode with me.
He goes looking for bigfoot with me and
Ari Shaffir did some episodes as well.
Uh, so, uh, I'm bringing in a lot of
my friends were going to have some fun.
Brian Cantwell, I'm sure eventually one.
You will. I love you buddy. All right.
Thank you everybody. We will see
you tomorrow with a Duncan Trussell.
He'll be on tomorrow.
Um, and uh, thanks to uh,
oh tomorrow night we're at the ice house.
If you get this,
we're having like a little party at the
ice house doing a little standup comedy
show. Uh, it's so far, Tom
Segura, Duncan Trussell,
Brian Red Banh me and uh, so I'm sure
some of the people will be there too.
We always have a big show at the ice
house in Pasadena because we loved them.
squarespace.com, uh, go use the
code word Joe and the number seven.
That's one word,
Joe and the number seven.
And you will save yourself
10% you dirty freaks.
Squarespace is all you need to build a
bad ass motherfucking website easily.
You can do it. I can do it.
Everybody can do it. Thanks.
Also to [inaudible] dot
com go to o, n n I. T,
use the code name Brogan and stick it
right up your pooper. How about that? Huh?
Huh? How about that? Poop and
then you save some money. No,
you put it up your butt and you save 10%
all right. We'll see you guys tomorrow.
Thank you for all the love.
Thank you for all the links on Twitter.
All the shit that you guys send me.
It is the coolest connection.
I would just love the fact that it's
this massive resource of information and
cool videos and clips and websites
and I can't say it enough.
I say it all the time, but I can't
say it enough. I love you guys.
I appreciate the fuck out of here.
Thank you very much. See you soon.
Okay.
Yeah.